we got a great big convoy up in canada
and american truckers are joining with
canadian truckers protesting vaccine
mandates get this they're estimating 50
000 truckers that sounds that sounds
crazy to me they can't be right but
they're saying it stretches nearly 50
miles this trucker convoy in protest and
trudeau
shaking in his boots said it's just a
small fringe minority are you kidding
this is massive this story is getting
really really big so we're gonna get
into this we got a bunch of other
stories evangeline lilly star of ant-man
and the wasp
went down she's a hollywood celebrity
went to the dc anti-mandate protest
publicly endorsed the message getting
roasted but wow bravo i'm really
surprised to hear that someone out of
hollywood is doing the right thing
which brings us to
uh dan bongino he's getting censored his
youtube channel has been deleted and uh
we got joe rogan in the news again and i
think the story is escalated now to
something totally different the amount
of hit pieces that just came out about
joe i mean we talk about him quite a bit
and it's always kind of like oh look at
they're talking about joe rogan again
now it's like cnn the verge independent
outlets across the board are writing
different crazy stories they first tried
going for the nuclear option you know we
we got a list of doctors that didn't
work now they're trying the the marvel
jericho missile method if you're
familiar with iron man they're just
layering
all these different hit pieces
and it says something really interesting
that i think is actually good news
joe has set the news cycle he controls
it now every time they try and go after
him for what he what someone else says
what one of his guests says
joe owns the news cycle and if they keep
playing into this
they're done the media's the media is
digging their own grave so we'll get
into all this stuff joining us today to
talk talk about all of this is kerry
sheffield
do you want to introduce yourself hey
tim what camera do i look at i'm sorry
okay
there's so many um hey everybody i'm
carrie sheffield i am a senior policy
analyst with the independent women's
forum we believe that all issues are
women's issues
we are not pigeonholed as women
and we believe in limited government we
believe in freedom and we believe that
people should be able to make their own
choices about their lives i mean these
are just basic american concepts oh yeah
there's a there's a really interesting
story we might be able to get into about
this app called giggle have you heard
about it no it's a female only app that
uses facial recognition to determine if
you're female and it's caused a huge
uproar in the lgbtq community because
facial recognition doesn't care about
what you identify as
so we'll maybe maybe we'll get into that
later on though but it's very
interesting yeah it is it is it will be
interesting philosophically and
scientifically uh we have sheamus good
to be here thank you for having me back
again who are you i am the creator of
freedom tunes if you want to check out
my youtube channel i do political
cartoons as well as educational cartoons
and political commentary and every now
and again tim begs me and he says
sheamus come on to my podcast please
shameless
so famous that he doesn't need to to
explain what he does everybody knows
he's correct you see you're making
assumptions i just figured no one's
gonna care who i am okay it's it's
coming from a place of humility
all right well i i i i i agree
thank you buddy
i don't know if this is going to play on
camera you should have got me this uh
beautiful new beanie he was trying to
gag you i think there's more parts to it
but i didn't i think you look like the
kid on the christmas story
no i think ralphie
i'm a knight from the middle ages well
it also has everyone the glasses kind of
they're [ __ ] up
there's a there's a beard you're
supposed to attach to it oh cool
look at the full size everybody ian
crossland over here i want you to follow
me on uh ian crossland.net is it ian we
can't tell this isn't going to work
i thought you were wearing a mask thanks
tim that beard has a mouth hole you're
supposed to attach it to the i know it
should have you should have been going
well you should have prepared yourselves
yeah that's my emma welcome wardrobe
thank you
uh hey hi looking forward to the
conversation let's get down and dirty
fifty thousand truckers man that's yeah
is that real let's find out yeah we're
gonna find out um i'm always happy when
i have ladies on especially ladies from
the iwf so we're gonna have a great
conversation show and we can get into it
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member to help
support all of the work we do here we
are principally funded by memberships it
is it is it what makes everything
operate it was it it employs our
journalists it allows this show to
continue and as a member you'll get
access to exclusive members only
segments of this podcast we will have a
special members only segment for you
guys up around 11 or so p.m after the
show they're usually around a half an
hour long you don't want to miss them
they're good fun we have a lot of really
awesome people and you could look back
at the entire library with people like
andrew torba and steve bannon and alex
jones and marjorie taylor green it's all
really really good fun so uh help
support our work over at teamcast.com
but don't forget to smash that like
button right now subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
that's the marketing power of the
grassroots effort we can't compete with
all these big companies but if you guys
just take 10 seconds to go copy paste
boom
if everyone did that we'd be crushing
the mainstream media but now let's get
into that big story it's from the daily
mail american truckers join canada's
freedom convoy protesting vaccine
mandate as rigs stretch for 45 miles
trudeau plays it down and calls
protesters a small fringe minority look
at this
with 50 000 truckers driving from
vancouver the freedom convoy 2022 is
demanding that their government abolish
vaccine passports
they say as many as 32 000 or about 20
of truckers are not vaccinated now
there's so much craziness to this story
aside from the fact this line is massive
gofundme what do they raise like five
million dollars already is that it well
that's what i heard yesterday that they
had canceled a five million dollar froze
it froze yeah i think they released it
oh this is big it's it's amazing because
we had that big dc protest you know this
past weekend uh robert malone when joe
rogan's podcast had mentioned we're
gonna go to dc in protest wasn't that
big it was not that big i think luke was
down there and he said maybe 10 20 000
people and i was like well you know but
now we're getting 50 000 truckers
stretching 45 to 50 miles it looks like
gofundme is releasing 1 million of the 5
million
for some reason not all 5 million i
don't i i can't
understand why they would even use
gofundme yeah no i don't know why you
would at this point it's interesting
because this article that we were all
looking at points out that the longest
convoy prior to that was five miles long
yes and you have justin trudeau saying
this is a small fringe protest because
this is what they do anytime they want
to turn public perception against the
popular movement they either claim it's
not large or they ignore it they do it
at the march for life every single year
which is part of why i went there this
year to cover it because there were tens
of thousands of people there but they
always make it sound like it's a no-show
event how many people do you think were
down there at the
i couldn't estimate but it was tens of
thousands definitely well and it wasn't
just in dc too it's happening all over
the country yeah very true yeah
capitals for life is national yeah oh
yeah yeah
well vaccine passports
this is i've been waiting for the united
states for americans and canadians to
unify in some way against against
government overreach just americans and
other and other
you know people from around the world
australia
what's what is this going to mean for
our food and stuff you know because are
these guys effectively not working by
doing this there's already a trucker
shortage yeah exactly i mean i was sort
of talking about this yesterday but
the idea that we could afford to lose 20
of our truckers across any border if the
economy was doing well would be
ludicrous
with things as bad as they are it's
insane to even
have justin trudeau or any civil
authority ignore this pretend as if it's
not a big deal and try to force their
demands on the truckers he either
doesn't realize the leverage that they
have or more likely he realizes they do
have leverage but he doesn't care
because he's not going to get hurt when
the shelves aren't stocked you are
what i don't get is why are they
targeting truckers specifically because
most of your time you're alone in your
cabin
you're not i mean and so and okay maybe
you're at the flying j to pick up some
snacks
why not the motorist in the car the
four-wheelers you know agreed like
well
why truckers
how
for whom we rely on i don't understand
that and then i don't understand omicron
i think changed the calculus for
everything like you know it's just
breakthrough cases are everywhere so
whether you are vaccinated or not at
this point it is irrelevant to whether
you will get omicron if you look at all
of this through the lens of public
health you will be confused the whole
time
if you look at this through the lens of
someone trying to destroy economies
everything makes sense exactly why would
cuomo willfully kill people
andrew cuomo in new york was like i'm
gonna put sick people in nursing homes
and they'll die and he was warned that
would happen now why would he do that if
he was trying to save lives that
literally makes no sense the problem
because he got a lot of money from the
hospital associations
to sex campaign donations to his
campaign yeah but because they were
pressuring him because they wanted the
money right
no they put him in nursing homes well
they're nursing well the administrators
of both the hospitals and the nursing
homes the nursing home said give us sick
people they wanted the money
is that is that it
was killing all these people yeah
he wanted the campaign he was under
their pressure the nursing home said
give us more people to make us money
that's that as i understand it that's
what they want they wanted the people
there well then it killed people for
money well also i think a lot of this
makes more sense if you look at it
through the lens of these people being
control freaks who demand our compliance
so you asked why go after truckers i
think part of the reason is because they
just need to see people bend the knee i
think that's a huge reason why these
mandates are being pushed on people they
don't want you making your own medical
decisions they want to make those
decisions for you i believe that and i
think they view it as a challenge
well i think they view it as a challenge
to their authority if people don't take
the recommendations and do the things
they told them to do and they don't care
who has to get suffered who has to
suffer when those people are punished
that's what i believe it's too
simplistic i don't think so i think that
they i think that these people are
control freaks yeah but control freaks
that want something like the idea that
they're just like you know what we have
no reason to do this but we'll do it
anyway all right so here's the thing i
absolutely believe that there are
probably other motives there but i think
once people start standing up and saying
no then the new motivation becomes well
i need to make sure that they fall in
line because if they can say no to this
they can say no to the other demands i
make on them
i think a lot of this is political i
think there's political strategy behind
it definitely i think they uh you know
the interesting thing is that it spans
all these different countries you've got
europe enacting much of the same
policies that we enact here that you
know canada is doing now interesting
interestingly we're seeing in europe a
bunch of these countries start to end
their their their lockdowns like denmark
i think the netherlands um a few others
while some are getting even more strict
i don't i i i look at this to the lens
of a pandemic none of it makes sense
it's like you're trying to put a puzzle
together but if you've got the wrong
picture it's the pieces won't go
together
and if we look at look at this through
the lens of coordinated political
manipulation then it all makes sense
it does why go after truckers they're
destroying the economy
why destroy the economy i mean i don't
know man there's a bunch of different
reasons for one look at what bill de
blasio said that he wants to buy up the
buildings in new york city now that
they're worthless because people are
fleeing and turn them into public
housing so there's one good reason to do
it yeah you go to the truckers you
depress wages you smash small businesses
you transfer wealth back up to the
elites the elites who call themselves
the elites in the world economic forum i
mean that
looks you know plain and simple now i
suppose if you want to take it one extra
layer deep we can you know listen alex
jones talking about an alien
intelligence taking over but that one's
a little too far from that i can't go
there yeah global elites who are trying
to steal money from the working class
well that's history
well yeah that's that's socialism that's
marxism that's when that's human nature
to grasp more power that's just
ad infinitive that's how humans have
always been um and we see this in real
time right now in central america um
it's just heartbreaking to see that
a strong man strong woman whatever
dictator they don't care about the
people it's all about in cuba same thing
that that's how it is if you want if you
get power you're power hungry your power
drunk
unless you believe that the power rests
with the people then fundamentally if
you if you fundamentally don't believe
that the power rests with the people and
that you are better than them then
you're going to keep stealing more power
that's just human nature what i find
funny about this is the the the posts
and stories where it's like it's white
supremacists
you know like that that's their go-to
for everything yeah aliens is if that
well as if that's in any way an
explanatory narrative here like why
don't these people want to get this
injection oh they must hate black people
what are you talking about a bunch of
racists got in their trucks yeah
it makes no sense but well not to
mention the vaccine hesitancy among
black americans is i think in many cases
a lot higher than white people
especially
but they didn't they're doing that again
that's white supremacy because they're
trying to scare black people to not get
they're doing the same thing right now
with a march uh march for life yeah of
course the the patriot front group that
no sane person thinks is an actual group
i know it was apparently at the march
for life and now all these articles pop
up where they're like why white
supremacists like the pro-life movement
or whatever and i'm like i don't
understand why they would that makes no
sense yeah that's absolutely insane what
about margaret sanger she was a white
supremacist and she founded planned
parenthood so explain that to me or the
locations of planned parenthood yeah
exactly exactly but that's why
you know that's not an indictment from
me personally on planned parenthood's
choice of locations the left has their
arguments for it i'm just pointing out
why would a white supremacist be upset
with that yeah why why would they be
like oh gee oh darn no they would
probably be in favor of those those
those clinics no in fact i think uh live
action called up a planned parenthood
and said um i'd like to specifically
target a donation to specifically target
uh for black women
and they and they said they said yeah um
yeah send it on over and and
he's like he's like yeah that is
wokeness cranked up to 11. i'm sure
you've got some critical race theorists
like woke you know uh planned parenthood
woman nurse or whatever and she's like
that's so nice of you yeah no it's true
he asks over the phone i can't remember
if it was live action but i don't
remember veritas but it might have been
i don't remember but i do remember this
guy over the phone like i i want to make
a donation for people to have abortions
like
could it go like specifically to like
minority he's like dancing around it a
little bit but he basically says yeah
can you like make sure this donation
goes to getting black babies aborted and
they're like yes of course
wow
because the way they twist it in their
head and i have to put the disclaimer
independent women's form is uh neutral
on abortion but i'm personally in
pro-life um and that's the thing about
the right is that we allow for dispersed
opinion on this if you there are almost
no pro-life democrats uh they just for
example tried to book a you know
democrats for life tried to book a meal
for during the march for life
at a restaurant i think bus boys and
poets in dc
their reservation was canceled once they
found out that these were democrats for
life um but i am personally pro-life but
there's actually a lot of democrats that
are pro-life it's huge yeah but but
they're suppressed by the establishment
and then you can't fundraise especially
if you're a female democrat good luck
getting money and i would say they're
not particularly pro-life if they're
willing to just vote democrat knowing
they're voting against their own
interests exactly but not not to derail
the conversation speaking of truckers
they're doing the same thing but it's
the same old tired playbook i'm tired of
saying it i'm tired of hearing it but uh
to be honest it's getting to a point
where now it's uh it's comical it's like
oh you're doing that thing again you
you're claiming the protesters are
racists exactly wow what year is it is
it 20 2016
oh it's 2022. well and this is a new bit
there was uh there was an incredibly
insightful article written in 2016 and i
can't remember who wrote it
unfortunately but their whole point was
after the election they realized that
they couldn't go around calling people
racist anymore and it wasn't that they
realized that you can't just call people
names they just understood that that
term had lost its meaning so they
started saying white supremacist after
that and then they started saying white
supremacists all the time and now i
think they've moved on to they're really
playing with using like incitement of
violence as their new term threat to
democracy or threat to democracy yeah
but it's it's just the same way of
saying the same the different way of
saying the same thing which is that
you're disobedient it's chicken little
just running around screaming the sky is
falling it's the boy who cried wolf i
gotta be honest i literally don't care
yeah someone could be marching around
protesting anything and they would be
like that person's racist and i'd like
huh
what else is on i don't care i don't
speaking of threat to democracy i just
read a really great piece about the
actual threat to democracy right now is
the soros-funded das who are literally
ignoring the will of the people by
choosing to pick and choose whatever
they feel like prosecuting these are
laws that have been passed by the
legislative branch there's a thing
called separation of powers that says
the executive branch is is supposed to
it's not optional you can't
the d.a in new york for example can just
unilaterally decide something these
aren't suggestions so that is the actual
threat to democracy and i'm really glad
to see people like my former boss john
solomon uh he's he's been able to do
some great reporting about this and
enforcing uh documents uh for example in
missouri the prosecutor
who was source funded in st louis um
people are starting to wake up let's
talk about the narrative breaking we've
got the story from nbc news marvel actor
evangeline lilly shares that she
attended
anti-vaccine mandate rally the
anti-vaccination mandate rally held
sunday made headlines because of
comments from robert f kennedy jr
comparing policies to the holocaust and
even after that evangeline lilly was
still willing to publicly come out and
be like yo i was there because i believe
in this evangeline lilly you rock you're
awesome you did a great job in ant-man
and ant-man and the wasp big fan and for
you to come out now and and stand up for
what you believe in in the face of of
this psychotic media going after
everybody smearing people lying about
people that is brave that is principled
i respect it and it shows for everybody
else you know when hollywood's
celebrities start coming out and saying
nah that's good news yep the narrative's
broken
yeah also i mean
of course you know holocaust comparisons
between the holocaust and events where
no one is being killed are so tired at
this point that even pointing out that
they're tired is tired yeah people are
losing their minds over it but it's like
everyone does it all the time
particularly i mean it happens way more
often on the left but
so so banal at this point but you know i
mean good for her for standing up for
the truth and being willing to say yeah
i was at this mandate these are my
actual values because there are a lot of
celebrities i'm sure who can see through
this stuff i i have some faith that
there are at least some of them who are
capable of it but they're just not
saying anything yeah it's um the
government jumped the shark that's that
that idea from like a tv show and the tv
show's just gone too far it's had too
many new adoptions of little kids to you
know whatever uh it comes from happy
days when i think they literally jumped
a shark on a motorcycle trying to one-up
themselves over and over it gets so far
they're like well the show's jumped the
shark the government's jumped the shark
we know it because we've been watching
and we can relate it to 20 years ago or
15 years ago but young kids that see it
aren't going to realize that this is too
far and they might think that it's
normal this is just how government works
evangeline lilly's got 2.2 million
followers and she posted a picture of
vax democrat for medical freedom she
said i was in dc this weekend to support
bodily sovereignty while canadian
truckers were rallying for their
cross-country peaceful convoy in support
of the same thing yo this is epic i
believe nobody should ever be forced to
inject their body with anything against
their will under threat of violent
attack arrest or detention without trial
loss of employment homelessness
starvation loss of education alienation
from loved ones excommunication from
society under any threat whatsoever this
is not the way this is not safe it is
not healthy this is not love i
understand the world is in fear but i
don't believe that answering fear with
force will fix our problems i was
pro-choice before coven i am still
pro-choice today bravo evangeline lilly
that was an epic post and brave that is
you know what you know you know you know
what guys stunning and brave indeed yes
yes it is it was all based until that
last sentence but you know which i'm
glad she's being
i'm not being pro-choice in any capacity
but i hear what she's saying and it's
great because these are the people who
want to spend all of their time claiming
that they stand with the working class
and then when you have truckers who are
working class and are in many ways like
quite literally the backbone of the
economy if there's one group you're
going to point to and say we can make a
solid case that we absolutely need these
people as truckers and so for them to be
thrown under the bus
and
for us to look the other way especially
people on the left who are constantly
constantly harping on about like how
empathetic they are and how much they
care about the working class is
ridiculous so good for her i mean she's
doing what they claim they're supposed
to do well and ian to your point on
jumping the shark and and passing the
moment like i think biden him first of
all let's flash you know back in time
when the biden administration used to
say oh yeah we can't do a mandate that's
just something we can't do legally
and then
lo and behold they put the mandate in
place but lo and behold the supreme
court says no actually you can't and now
they're repealing their osha mandate so
i think even i mean the wave is crested
as far as the mandates are concerned and
i have to say this was an anti-mandate
rally which is contrary to what i think
it was cnn or msmc i forget what i said
they said it was an anti-vaccine rally
i'm like no you obviously don't
understand this is about the mandates no
they don't they're just lions of course
exactly
liars they are they're like thank you
for the correction
you know you know i'm i'm watching this
and we have a marvel references and what
just comes to mind with the mainstream
narrative is that scene from the new
spider-man movie where dr strange is
trying to contain the spell but it's out
of control and it just erupts and i'm
like that that is the that is the truth
that is reality and they're desperately
trying to contain it and it just breaks
free and then it shatters the multiverse
and then you know reality comes breaking
through not in that movie i don't know a
bunch of weirdos showed up like
spider-man from other movies but my
point is the narrative can't be
contained they're trying as hard as they
can it's it's an anti-vex protest of
racists and white supremacists and then
evangeline lilly is just like nah that's
why you got to stay alive all of you
it's important right now as hard as
things might seem stay alive because it
is shattering and twisting open this is
inevitable
yeah well i mean i think there's there's
really cause for hope here the fact that
they have to tie themselves into knots
over this when they have to lie about
how large your movement is and how large
the protests are in a lot of ways you're
in good shape it's a good problem to
have it really is because people are
waking up to it imagine the alternative
imagine if we had to pretend that our
protests were far larger than they were
whoever has to lie about the numbers is
losing trump always
was like
huge
am
his rallies were massive so a lot a lot
of them were really big but i mean you
know when they come out after the
inauguration
and it wasn't nearly that big it was big
and then they were like the biggest ever
it's like well if you include streaming
numbers then yes but everybody's always
trying to promote themselves and i i
certainly understand why but the media
does the opposite i remember during i
think it was during occupy wall street
this funny funny thing happened where a
local news station was covering the one
of the protests like a peripheral
protest in some city and they the camera
guy we actually watched him wait until
the end of the protest and then start
filming when there was like seven people
and then there were like people were
sharing it look at this video of their
report and it was like the protest was
quite small and it shows like yeah
that's what they do no i so i remember
when i was a child my parents would
sometimes take my siblings and i to pray
outside of either abortion clinics or in
one case christ hospital because they
were performing abortions there despite
the name of the hospital and media came
up
and started asking questions and as a
little child i'm not even like oh my
gosh what if they ask us questions and
we're going to be on tv and my dad says
shea they only go to old people they
only talk to the old people here they
don't want anyone to think that there
are young people interested in the
pro-life movement they they have to
curate a very specific image about who's
interested in this
i think that sounds pretty legit oh my
father's very legit
introduce him to us well where do we go
from here
we just keep doing what we're doing we
keep having a movement so strong that
they need to lie about how many people
believe in it i usually think like okay
if if this is true the narrative is
shattering and you know base reality is
coming back to fruition now it's our
chance to craft base reality we can
build that better what's it going to
look like you want to do a great reel
greater sheamus
i'm not in with this this world economic
forum thing
i wonder if this will precipitate some
other people coming out though you know
evangeline lilly is this is this because
we're seeing you know bill maher barry
weiss and other liberals now signal to
the left like hey it's safe now you can
come out of here big time yeah yeah
that's the barry weiss thing i i is
maybe as cringe as you pointed out it
comes a year late i'm still glad it
happened because it's it was so high
profile the question is whether she's
going to get cancelled
at this point
i mean
they might try but i don't think so
because her attitude is very defiant she
doesn't care you know what i mean it's
when when when people immediately become
demure and back down you know they don't
mean it but i mean it looks like she
really means it i think she i don't
think she just posted this this image i
think she made a video about it but let
me let me pull up her instagram and
we'll take we'll take a look
you know what else i'd kind of like to
suggest this i haven't looked into this
because the thought just came to me but
i would be curious to see how likely
these large studios are
to refuse to work with famous
celebrities when their stock price is
down
because right now the market's not doing
too great and i wonder if that gives
leverage to entertainers and performers
maybe but it does yeah well when the
industry is is is flopping you know we
had uh christian toto on talking about
hollywood freaking out when that when
hollywood's losing their power and
everyone's in panic because they're
aging out the movies aren't making as
much money
i mean
these these marvel movies are
blockbusters they're massive the billion
dollar movies but the industry itself it
looks like it's in a downward trajectory
outside of that everything's
consolidating
originality is is on the decline you
know wokeness it and maybe it may be
even that that people have finally
realized get won't go broke yeah there
was a story about the new superman comic
i was reading from uh bounding into
comics the new superman comic where
superman's son is is bisexual it sold
like half what the other one sold
now i don't know we talked about it some
were saying it's because the the the the
the companies
decide to sell less to comic book stores
like that but i'm like okay maybe i
can't i don't know the nitty gritty of
this but i do know that people are
complaining about they don't want to buy
it you know if the fans don't like it
they don't buy it so maybe that stuff's
having an impact and now people uh
hollywood celebrities might just be like
it doesn't matter anymore because this
whole narrative on the left is
ineffective it loses money
when you look at
and it could even be as simple as joe
biden's approval rating people look and
they're like democrats are not popular
and they're retiring in mass i'm jumping
[ __ ] before it's too late also like you
said earlier carrie the omicron changed
the the
the terrain it basically changed the
layout of what's going on with with
covet it's it's a less deadly
more contagious or i don't even know is
it it's endemic yeah
yeah it's more contagious it's it's more
mild but uh 2.0 in hollywood the chosen
and if if y'all haven't seen the chosen
you need to see the chosen it's free you
guys know about the chosen i've heard
good things okay so the chosen is a
cereal
video series about the life of christ
and it was the most successful
crowdfunded movie project ever
and it was just christians who wanted to
have the story of jesus told
and that you know it's with acting and
it's just very well done it's incredible
the details uh it's so it's sort of like
fan fiction but it's actually you know
based on the bible not making a bunch of
stuff up um
but uh
they then because the serial like they
they released it basically like a tv um
series they then decided to do a
christmas special in
box office and it actually this chris
this past christmas season just came out
in box office it actually the opening
weekend per theater shattered all the
big hollywood films including they they
defeated on revenue poor theater house
of gucci which was like this you know
huge money suck um so it was incredible
and that just shows and i actually
interviewed the the executive producer
of the chosen i said how did you guys
slay the giant here i like how did you
guys do this and um they said well it
it's just the content and and i said
well i'm sure now at this point as you
were so successful you've been
approached by big houses and he said
yeah but we're not we're not going to
surrender we're not going to give that
up because they're they're going to try
to pervert what we want to
preach which is the gospel of jesus uh
and they're giving away for free and and
their goal is to to have it in in the
hands i think of two billion people i
mean they've already had you know
hundreds of millions of people have
viewed this so it's incredible yeah good
for them we were sort of speaking about
hollywood and the fact that they're
failing and i think obviously a huge
reason why new companies like this are
becoming successful is because there's a
niche in the market that needs to be
filled people don't want to be preached
at or ironically even when they do want
to be preached at least want it to be
entertaining and i think there are
obviously ways of spreading christian
morals and messages that don't come off
as preaching which are genuinely
entertaining now when it comes to
whether traditional hollywood is going
to be able to turn this spiral around
and climb back up i think the answer is
probably no and the reason that i'm
saying that it's not just out of a sense
of optimism here and i could be wrong
but i don't think this is a group of
people who on the individual level are
interested in success i believe because
of their ideology they see themselves as
victims and they're satisfied
complaining about how corrupt the system
is when they fail so they don't need to
get a taste of success i think these are
you know when it comes to hollywood when
it comes to the establishment left in
the media these are people who are only
satisfied if someone else tells them
they're worthy
so that's why they all just virtually
signal to each other but eventually that
group becomes so broken and just brittle
that they have no choice but to seek
validation outside of that exactly and
so i think that's part of what we're
seeing you know look for for evangeline
lilly to come out and say this is
amazing and it's glad to see it's
happening among celebrities
who was there first is the question you
know who who are the people that were
always standing up for people's rights
that always stood on principle never
backed down never questioned it
i mean those are the people of true
principle so i can certainly say thank
you to everybody who's coming around
being like we were wrong about this it's
good to admit you were wrong or if you
never spoke up about it speaking up
about it now it's a good thing thank you
for joining the fray but i think it's
important to to you know
keep that eye out some people are just
looking for validation and if they can't
get it anymore because their site has
gone nuts they'll just pretend like they
want validation from you or or at least
they do want it and they're desperate
for any kind of of adoration you know
people who don't know how to think for
themselves so they just say to you you
know
tell me what to say tell move to think
yeah yeah exactly exactly yeah i think
we saw a little bit of that with claire
lehman and colette where they kind of
insinuated their way into what was
considered the ideological dark web
which was that right wing let me turn
myself up a little bit um and they kind
of told right-wingers what they wanted
to hear until it came an opportunity for
them to be authoritarianism and then the
judge oh yeah yeah
for those aren't familiar with with
colette and claire lehmann i mean this
is a really good example of the the
inverse this is a this is a publication
that claimed to be like the intellectual
dark web outlet
now the founder is pro relocation camp
for covid patients and for the coveted
suspects in australia the coalette and
the founder are are
opposing efforts to get critical race
practices out of schools calling it
censorship and anti-free speech
so you they they came in they said come
come come give us give us money give us
money and then as soon as they had the
opportunity they just did that shift and
they were like actually we were cultist
authoritarians the whole time so what's
surprising to me is how many people i
know still give quillette money yeah
like people people who are following me
on twitter
or i'll see people tweet about it and
i'm just like wow
you know there there are people that you
know i've met and i'm like how are you
still
involved in this organization that is
outright pro-critical race theory that
is outright supportive of relocation
camps for people suspected of coming
into contact with another person who may
have had covid that have act that they
support and defend and lie to protect
police going to the homes of people and
taking them without charge or trial to a
camp
they're like that's a good thing but um
what is it claire and then josh zepps i
think works for them too isn't it i
don't know if he works for them he's a
he's a broadcaster with the australian
broadcaster okay isn't it that they're
basically under duress from their
government it'd be like living in nazi
germany and having to be like yeah the
nazis are just fine wink wink get out of
here wait hang on hang on no no i've
known josh steps for a long time he's
he's from the left so i'm shocked to
know that okay i didn't know this this
change about colette so my i would
imagine that a lot of people are still
giving them money because this is a news
to me i didn't realize they had turned
so sharply left so if they're still
getting money from people on the right
it's because they might not know the
shift just happened because josh sheps i
mean he's a nice person but he is he is
not a conservative in any sort of right
sort of way but i mean so it's
interesting but because that must be a
new recent thing because when i've
worked with him it was you know 2016
when he he would he was the left guy
well colette was like
well claire lehmann worked for rebel in
canada i'm pretty sure so that's very
conservative but by authoritarianism you
can be liberal or conservative and still
be an authoritarian well that's true
address your point ian i have to say no
they're not they may be under some
duress to a certain degree but if avi
yemeni can go out in australia this
reporter this journalist this
personality and stand in front of police
officers and say you cannot make me
leave i'm a journalist
okay if he can do that quillette can
certainly be like we think it's bad
they're putting people in camps because
avi does you know he does it all day
every day so there's a guy who has
principles and a backbone who's
challenging the authoritarianism
collette they they they you know played
their little flute and attracted
everybody to come over and throw money
to them and then now it's just been like
the state is great
those camps can go wrong when um
and like a flood and then people are
stuck in the camp that's when the guards
start have to make split-second
decisions that's when things can go
really bad is if the guards are gonna
have to no leave their post for some
emergency you don't want people stuck in
the camps the the camps went bad when
the camps existed yeah
the idea of like a landing zone camp is
understandable for incoming people and a
quarantine and that kind of understand
like no
well i mean i understand the idea of a
quarantine you 40 days in port you wait
and then they let you into the country
that's the history of the word
quarantine from venice
yeah building camps yeah is is
it's the first step to be fair it's a
it's a it's a piece on the chessboard
that it can be used for great
authoritarian
damage but it also could be used for for
its you know benevolent use but when an
emergency happens that's when you see
the guards are like i can't let these
people out there's no there's no running
water anymore well people are like
starving
what's to say these camps wouldn't
become super spreader events themselves
that's what i don't understand because
wasn't that the whole thing of of
liberals at the border because they were
saying oh we can't detain any illegal
immigrant because they're going to be in
these super spreader camps so we should
just let them all go
so that's that's what makes no sense to
me about these camps in australia just
from a logistical standpoint josh zapps
is the guy who said that they were
international arrival bungalows
one that sounds like an airbnb
and then claire is the one who took a
bunch of these propaganda photos of
olympic athletes of like you know hot
babes she called it and there she was
like look at all the hot babes in this
relocation camp she didn't say
relocation camp but i did
and so uh
we made a shirt
that's uh people on a beach with razor
wire in front of him and a guy running
from a police boat and it says
visit howard springs totally voluntary
relocation camp yeah that's actually why
luke left he saw those women he's like i
got to go down
there i know it just reminds me of this
reminds me of was it fry fest
remember that big scandal where
firefighters yeah sorry sorry yeah we're
like the who who was the guy doing it he
raised like millions of dollars and
we're supposed to be this
magic camp where all these like
influencers oh i remember with bottled
water and yeah they got suited they got
suited
have no that's how it was having a
failed event it's not the same as
conning people you know what i mean
that's true
i'm just saying from a marketing
standpoint luxury remember when uh
remember when tumblr tumblr con or
whatever it was oh my goodness
the inflatable ball pit yeah it was just
it was like a kiddie pool i was there
it was in the balls dude derby come on
yeah they like they were like we're
gonna do a convention for tumblr and
then you know everybody bought tickets
but then it was a big empty like
warehouse with like an inflatable kiddie
pool from walmart full of
balls
wow really really bad but so like i
don't i wouldn't consider that a fraud
or a scam just because someone's
incompetent you know what i mean so i'm
just saying if you're calling it a
bungalow like that words matter that's
all that's what i'm saying and then of
course he's the guy who went on uh he
went on joe rogan's show and
said you know essentially that me and
maggie nawaz were alt-right yeah and
then joe rogan calls him out and he says
well not magic because i know magic it's
like so you're saying tim cool
alt-right means i don't know them
no it's just these these people are
i'm i'm gonna say like i think they're
evil people
so uh many of you look josh i don't
think josh is evil i just i just
he's supporting camps where the police
go to women they went to a woman's home
and they said you were being arrested
without charge or trial and she said she
was told it was because she lied to them
that they took her from her home and put
her in a camp for two weeks this guy
lied about what these camps were doing
defended it accused me of being
alt-right for suggesting it lied about
my characterization of what was going on
on joe rogan's show joe didn't have
enough information to defend what i'd
actually said this dude is evil
when they have camps and the police go
to your home and say come with us we
have the authority to take you with uh
under duress with no due process and
he's going on the radio and saying
everybody it's all right go along with
the police get in the train car get in
the train car yeah that's evil that is
an evil
i'm not going to swear it's an evil guy
one hundred percent okay so here's my
question is josh steps though more a
product because josh is sort of a and
his his personality i'm not saying his
beliefs i don't believe that he's an
affable likeable person i think he's
just doing this because the system is
you know telling him he has to do this
in order to whatever
that's hold on no no no no in order the
banality of evil
well yeah no that's what i'm saying well
yeah but that's what i'm saying so is he
i guess it's all about uh intent is he
intentionally evil or is he not i don't
think he's interested
you can say he's kind generous and
honest and still evil like that's those
that can be
true like let's be let's be honest lex
luthor right a character in comic books
often does try to save the world but he
doesn't care who he kills in the way
doctor doom for the same reason i'm not
i'm not saying that josh epps is on par
with any of these super villain
characters but when he comes out and
he he first i'll be i'll be i'll be i'll
be kind
when i when i uh somewhat hyperbolically
said that these camps were concentration
camps as the holocaust museum defines it
that's a camp where you're taken without
due process that's that's literally how
the holocaust museum defined it
so i'm not even you know i'm i'm
somewhat trolling on twitter and i've
admitted that i'm like i'm just pushing
buttons and like you know posting silly
nonsense so he he gets mad and he's like
calling an international a rival
bungalow a concentration camp is wrong
and then i'm like okay you know my
response was i was being a little
hyperbolic that i can accept but come on
international rival bungalow my point
was it's only a matter of time before
they round up their own citizens and
send them to the camp and after that did
happen and i was proven right he still
lies about what i said quillet does
everything in their power to
mischaracterize my claims when i said
you had the i think it was the premier
of the northern northern territories i
don't know a whole lot about australian
politics to be honest i have a bunch of
friends down there i talk to them quite
often they tell me what's going on so
then i read news stories he said that
the people who live in these areas no
longer had the right to leave their
homes unless it was a medical emergency
that means you can't even leave your
home for food
that's what i said how did they
characterize what i said the state is
depriving them of food no i said you
can't even leave your home to get food
so if you're hungry you got to wait and
then his response but they're delivering
food to their homes i'm like great when
the state locks you in your house like
china did like the chinese communist
party did when they show up to your
house and take you by by vehicle to a
camp and and you then you lie about what
i said you lied to defend it and then
you accuse me of being alt-right and
attempt to deflect the entire
conversation i'm sorry there's no way
you can argue that man is not an evil
piece of garbage
well good for you for admitting that you
spoke you know you even said okay i was
trolling and he didn't have the courage
to respond in any sort of gracious you
know or whatever they mentioned you know
tim even acknowledged that he was being
facetious a bit or whatever and i'm like
right i'm not literally saying that
they're you know putting australians in
gas chambers no but they are
concentrating them in camps the the
holocaust museum of spay to spade man
get over it so i think it was it was it
was i don't know um
there's a holocaust museum website i
think it may be out of it might be out
of illinois and they said what makes a
concentration camp different from a
normal prison they said when you are
placed there without due process
and i'm like okay well if that's their
definition but i wasn't even getting to
that point i was just saying like the
historical and uh traditional definition
was where people were being heavily
concentrated typically in a time of war
conflict yeah in nazi germany they
weren't being gassed at the
concentration camps in the beginning
either they were just concentrating
people there well some of them they're
just moving them but some of them not in
the very beginning some of them were
always
camps at first well i i think i think
history will show and is already showing
that josh ups is on the absolute wrong
side of everything
he's on the wrong side of science he's
on the wrong side of policy he's on the
wrong side of economics so at the end of
the day i don't really care what josh
steps
has to say so
props to you i'm on your side 100
i guess my point is that
you know as far as so for independent
women's forum we're all about trying to
get persuadable people and so
we try to be as we like to say happy
warriors we don't we don't try to use
language that is so hyperbolic that
we're going to turn people off but the
problem is in this day and age when
everyone is always about throwing bombs
and trying to be the most outrageous
jumping the shark you know
how how does something reasonable how
does it break through
is that why we have to use the most
extreme language to go after somebody
like josh like that's what i find so
upsetting because i'm like i don't i
don't want to call him an evil person i
think he's totally wrong and i think
he's just on the wrong side of
everything but like at what point do we
you know turn people off by being so you
know hyperbolic well that's what josh is
saying this is a challenge there's a
line and that line is if someone's going
around you know murdering uh babies for
instance
like
do you just say we don't think that's
evil we just disappeared that is evil
yeah whoa whoa whoa i agree whoa whoa i
agree that is that is evil yeah so so
what i'm saying is there are good people
there are people who are good
who who believe in abortion as in like
they
to them they don't understand why it's
evil
just so are you so everyone who's got an
abortion is an evil person
but how about a guy who goes around and
lies about what they're actually doing
and tells you all of the truths and
realities when you guys go out and say
here's what they're actually doing and
then someone goes in the room and says
don't listen to them they're lying
they're actually white supremacists you
you none of that happens they're not
selling body parts that's all not true
listen to my voice listen
is that is it evil to go on the radio
and tell millions of people that the
truth is actually not true
if if in order to to you know so look
there have been a bunch of stories about
uh planned parenthood and the selling of
body parts and we covered them on this
show but you go to some of these news
websites and they will outright tell you
it never happened yeah is that is that
evil
is it evil
might be ignorant well i so also i think
this is it yeah absolutely it's evil no
i agree planned parenthood is evil yeah
and i guess like i said it's all about
intent so if
i think a lot of things are repeated in
the media because of peer pressure and
because they actually don't take the
time they're not intellectually curious
there's so much group think so i think
there are a lot of people who might
repeat something because they don't
actually know that it's evil so in that
case is the intent of them repeating a
lie that's so yeah i guess
it's splitting splitting hairs here but
i i think it's important from just like
a messaging student let me let me ask uh
so when josh zapp's
you know when my when i said my point
was that it's a it's only a matter of
time before they take australian
citizens and bring them there when he
discovered that was true
would it then still
would it then still be uh good for him
to lie about what i said and not admit
he was wrong no that would be evil i
guess that's what i'm saying is the
intent and and the the ignorance you
know it's all about intent and ignorance
so if someone is truly ignorant about
what they're saying how can you judge
them as the same as someone who is not
truly investigated that's that's my
night oh yes
malicious yeah well also i think there's
a really important distinction we need
to make here because i think you guys
might agree but the way the language is
coming across there seems as if there's
more of a disagreement than there is we
can make a distinction between this
person is evil and this action was evil
so we can say that a particular
individual might not be morally culpable
for engaging in an evil behavior because
they didn't know better but said
behavior was still evil
yeah yeah the sin versus the sinner will
exactly love the sinner hate this
exactly i guess that that's yeah and
that's a very
you know that's what jesus said but i
see i see what the colette people are
doing as willful yeah no i agree with
that if if you know better then that is
i agree that's evil if you intentionally
know the damages of of crt and what it
does to race relations what it does to
black people it tells them they are
hopelessly uh you know basically damned
uh that's evil i agree and if you know
that and you're now
lying willfully maliciously then yeah i
think that's evil but i think it's all
about how how much do you know that's
all right right but so that would just
be the banality of evil right so the
people in nazi germany who are just like
i was just following orders or whatever
exactly we called that the banality of
evil but you're talking about
premeditated evil yeah malicious
intentional construction and that's what
i'm saying is like okay and i guess i'm
saying this all as someone who
was raised in a very abusive cult
when someone came at me and tried to
attack me that's the whole point of a
cult is that it actually made me trench
in more yeah so that that's my fear when
we go around and and call people evil
without putting the the knowledge and
the education in front of it then they
actually entrenched even more that's
josh zeb's when he was on rogan
specifically said he felt like he would
be talking to one of his friends and be
like well the thing is
okay they said they were concentrating
they're actually just and then tim is
out there being like no don't listen to
him don't listen to josh
they are constantly listening and so
josh feels attacked you can tell from
the way he was explaining it that he
felt that you were irrationally
attacking and that's the lie because
that's the miscommunication what he was
saying was when he was talking to
australian people
but
we we don't have a particularly
prominent australian audience at all i
know for a fact i look at the numbers i
know the geographics i know that people
in australia do listen to us sometimes
and they and they super chat saying like
the hours are wonky because of when you
guys go live in eastern time but his
point was that when he's talking with
people in australia who mostly don't
know who we are
no he was he was angry because in my
opinion even joe said this he and and i
don't even know if joe was int was
joking he was just like are you working
for the state he's like because every
every criticism comes up you deflect you
defend and he's like they got you on
those state drugs what is it
and so i'm like
then joe comes out in a later episode
and he was like that dude you can't do
that accuse imagine noise and tim pool
of being all right or whatever but i
don't want to keep harping on this one i
think everyone gets the point can i just
mention one more thing because you made
a really interesting point about how
you're not really going to persuade
people if you come at them in too harsh
away and i think ultimately it's a
question of whether the person you are
interacting with is someone you can say
with any degree of certainty is acting
in good faith right and so oftentimes
there are people who really don't know
better and so i'll have a conversation
with somebody about abortion or
homosexuality or something where i
believe they're misinformed and i think
in that case it doesn't make sense to
sit there and tell them that they're an
evil person but then again if i'm
speaking to an abortionist who knows
what's happening who's actually killing
these children i mean that person is
evil so there's going to be a different
approach i think yeah no i i agree with
that and i think also because like i
said for what i do on a day-to-day basis
i'm trying to reach women sadly women
are so susceptible to the total bs of
crt they're so much more susceptible to
the language of the left i mean the the
even the new york times actually did
this big long write-up about gender
differences on college campuses and how
compared to the 80s
believe it or not men in the 80s
according to the study were actually
more liberal than women in the 80s uh
and flash word now where liberal women
are far more liberal and women have
bought into the lies of crt and just all
of this the sexual you know total i
didn't want to swear but just made up
stuff um about uh you know
the patriarchy and things like that so
it's like okay how do i reach a female
audience and and telling them their evil
to spread out dragonflies or something
just for no reason
and then you're you're like hey they
shouldn't do that because those
dragonflies are actually killing
mosquitoes or something
i wouldn't comment them and be like you
evil
excuse me yeah did you know and if they
say
that's interesting hey everybody this
guy's lying and he's racist i bet okay
this person's evil exactly person's
acting in bad faith they're malicious
they want to destroy they want to cause
harm or they believe they have rights
over you and they should lie to you to
control you so if the average person is
engaging in something that's bad well
yeah you you treat them like a regular
person in fact i don't even give them
it's not even about one chance it's
about two three chances what if you talk
to a little kid and he's like you're
stupid and you're like no actually i'm
actually kind of smart and the kids like
no you're stupid is the kid evil just
because he keeps telling you you're a
liar he's like no you're a racist liar
you're like no i'm not and he's like
yeah racist lie like is that
six-year-old evil because he's repeating
this stuff
his he reached this
he's not evil but but ian listen if that
six-year-old starts killing small
animals and you tell him to stop and he
tells you to shut up because you're
stupid and keeps doing it right he's
probably evil or is he yeah
i don't know man kids are just a product
of their environment for the most part
some kids have mental conditions and
they harm animals for no reason and they
don't stop and they grow up some kids
like burning things down and end up
killing people not every person is
always going to be a good person and
sometimes they're very young when they
do bad things yeah i think also i want
to
add something piggybacking off of what
you just said to clarify statement i
made earlier where i was referencing the
difference between your average person
who believes in abortion and abortionist
i'm also not suggesting that an
abortionist is someone who's completely
beyond redemption either i think that we
should try to persuade and help anyone
and everyone we can to see the truth but
obviously for different people there's
different approaches and some people are
going to be more difficult than others
but ian i would say that it's a question
of whether that child is past the age of
reason and of course children
are much more impressionable so i think
there's more hope in such a circumstance
that you're going to be able to
modify the behavior it's not as baked in
yeah i think it was frederick douglass
who said it's easier to build up healthy
children to repair broken men yes
so i think you know i want to go back to
something you were talking about with uh
women being more susceptible to to see
our crt and stuff and i'm wondering if
that's due perhaps to
you know the the the the trope of women
being more socially inclined and men
being more like physically inclined or
you know goal oriented you know what i
mean
yeah more uh
achievement or um
well i think there are it's personality
traits i mean i think this whole concept
of what's mass toxic masculinity is
something that is is sprung out of not
so crt is just you know one branch of
critical theory so there's the critical
gender theory critical race theory uh
critical class theory all of these
things so it's just it is one big
marxist lie at the end of the day but i
think women are more susceptible because
well in general women are more
liberal i mean i said the thing about
the 80s but generally speaking voting
patterns nationally is that women they
you know it's the road to hell is paved
with good intentions and so it always
sounds nice that marxism is this fairy
tale that sounds nice like why why would
you like everybody freezing what i'm
asking is it that's i feel like it's
inverted i feel like uh women are more
social than men so they're more likely
to vote democrat because of critical
race theory
so so if you look at uh instagram for
instance the women are substantially
more likely to get depressed over likes
and posting images than men do because
there's a social interaction of of of
being accepted and and you know being
cheered on by your peers so uh i'm not
i'm not a psychologist or an
evolutionary psychologist or a biologist
writing like that so i don't know
exactly if that's true just something
that i've read so i'm wondering you know
when i look at the poll from vox that
showed
70 around 70 percent of millennial women
are democrats
is this because of social behaviors
that men are less likely to be
influenced by
does that result in them yeah
that's interesting i mean i think there
is the group think and the virtue
signaling and the rewards so if you come
out and and
you say i'm you know i'm i'm a 12 year
old girl and i'm going to start getting
testosterone blockers you will get a lot
of instagram likes yeah um you're going
to be cheered you know and it's it's uh
and what if you
are a 13 year old girl and say i was
wrong about that and want to stop
you'll be shunned yeah is there any
evidence that show if women are more
likely to fall into cults than men
have you guys ever looked into that kind
of thing that is a good question well
well what's interesting is that uh there
were within mormonism which we were
talking about because my ancestors
helped found it uh polygamy it's a thing
they were i was just about to mention
uh in polygamy so
mormonism just in general well yeah i
think in i i think for sure in
practicing mormonism i think that's the
agreeableness uh jordan peterson's big
five personality traits i think this
agreeableness would be the one that
would make it people kind of just get up
get along go along to get along yeah
well yeah and and refuse to dissent the
dissent descent comes with a social cost
right so yeah so the way the left and
marxism has taken over the the cultural
outputs of media hollywood and academia
the the
rewards for dissension are
minimizing every day every year so that
might be part of it for sure tim i think
you're onto something i've i've found
multiple articles women are more likely
to be in cults than men makes sense so
this one is just from steemit so i'm not
sure it says it's from the independent i
just pulled it up on google and it says
women are more likely to attend
traditional religious service services
and more vulnerable to joining cults
there's a bunch of other articles uh
talking the same thing there was one
about nixium
which uh from the national post that
said women are more susceptible to being
to joining cults and there's another one
from 2014 about brazil and they said
majority of the women around the world
that majority of the people around the
world in cults are women
and tribal life was probably just like a
cult you got your tribal chief
who's the cult leader and then everybody
else and then in some cults or in some
cults and some like tribes cultures
where the word comes from they would
like
all share the the child wearing together
like all the men would have sex with all
the women and they would just no one
knew who the dad was they would just all
as a tribe raise the children very
cult-like it tends to be very effective
very modern-day cult like you would
consider that'd be a very weird
polygamist called what we're going to
say sheamus well i think another way of
of analyzing this and the political
differences that we tend to see between
men and women is it seems to be the case
and there are some smaller studies which
have suggested this but men are much
more comfortable with hierarchy than
women are women tend to be more
comfortable in egalitarianism that's the
new york times article was saying is
interesting okay yeah and it makes sense
and so you know there there's a time and
place for both because which is a very
marxist an idea
he got egalitarian promise of marxism
which is actually a lie because they
have their elite party leaders who are
you know by far the top of the hierarchy
no exactly and so i believe that there's
there's obviously value in this and i'm
you know a firm believer in
complementarianism and that men and
women are different and uh you know our
our strengths sort of complement one
another's weaknesses and vice versa
there are good reasons in some
circumstances to be skeptical of an
authority structure and so it's good
that that is baked into a women
generally in a way that's not baked into
men but also it is often the case where
the authority structure is fine and you
have to submit to it even if it hurts
your ego and in those cases a more male
way so to speak of thinking about the
issue tends to be the better one and
it's really interesting that we can
actually see how that affects people's
voting patterns
well it's interesting you said that
about the hierarchy with with business
because i remember that's something that
jordan peterson has said over and over
because uh you know
women in business are always like you
know men always run business and they're
it's all sexism why you know there's the
pay gap which we know is is mythological
and isn't real but but they they repeat
these lies because it makes them feel
good because there are there are fewer
female ceos uh and they're always saying
well we need to have you know a female
way of doing business but what as jordan
peterson says okay if there was an
actual
female way to do business versus milway
uh the market would reward this like if
if there was a non-hierarchical way to
do business successfully the market
would reward it but it doesn't because
it's not true who is james damore uh he
was google google it yeah and he
actually wrote we should change the way
we uh we do business here to accommodate
women they call them sexist for it the
weirdest thing to me is that here's a
guy who's saying i recognize that uh
women you know are in a patriarchy and
we should be more accommodating to them
and they were like burn the witch
or the warlock in this instance
yeah the wizard no but i mean he was
saying like women women work better in
different environments than men so why
don't we do this that or otherwise and
they were like it was a white
supremacist alt-right racist and it's
just like so when they agree with you
they're racist when they disagree with
you they're racist
sure it's like a mock being drawn to the
fire they're like come moths come to the
flame and then when they get too close
they're like
you did exactly what we wanted you to do
yeah it was a trick you spouted
and then also if there was a real pay
gap uh there would be no men ever hired
like if you could get the same quality
same caliber same credentialing of a
female worker for whatever
25 percent less hell y'all would be
unemployed except that argument assumes
men and women have the equal if equal
capabilities so i was i always thought
that was interesting because um there's
a video by uh this guy maddox you ever
you ever see it the the truth about the
wage gap or whatever he made a long time
ago it's actually really well done and
he's like want to know one one simple
reason why there's no such thing as a
payback pay gap because if there was no
company would ever hire men
unless
you had to pay the same but men were
better at the job
then they would only hire men exactly
yeah well it's so sad too that there are
people who want to deny the reality of
these differences because the world is
so beautiful in so many ways and one of
the things that makes it so beautiful is
the contrast between men and women and
if we deny that which makes us weaker
when we're apart we're also foregoing
that which makes us stronger when we
come together or at least acknowledging
that men and women really need each
other but when you want to have this
sort of strange flat
egalitarian marxist style thinking
surrounding gender you lose all that
there isn't any
such thing as a trait which is more
prevalent or common
among men you wouldn't refer to like the
masculine virtues or feminine virtues or
anything like that
yeah because it's like like celine dion
she creates a genderless line of baby
clothes because gender is just a
construct and you know which is so crazy
i went through a really codependent kind
of long-term relationship about six
years so i came out of it pendulum swung
the other way and i was like i want to
be in a relationship where we're equal
where we're both powerful
face you know alpha we're both you know
equal means the same so i tried to go
that route and it didn't work men and
women aren't the same no we're very
different
and sometimes i think women are not
equipped to play a support role it's not
that the man can't play a support role
but man women are good at it i don't
know if that's in that's a
generalization like the man is the tank
and the woman is the healer yes well
it's well and it's also again the cc
fans will all uh very wow this is all
very biblical so it's going to be very
offensive to people but yeah there's
just a natural law structure to things
where women do look to men for
leadership and women are miserable when
they're with men who won't step up and
take that role they don't enjoy that
they're sounding like jordan i know it's
like that's it's unbelievable here's the
thing that people understand about men
and women
to be leaders
keep going that's great it's like here's
the thing here's the thing can you
identify as jordan peterson can i get
you right now yeah you can get my
autograph yeah absolutely ladies and
gentlemen uh as long as jameis does
identify as dr jordan peterson then i
can write down that we have we had we
had him on the show that's true well the
thing is whenever you have one of those
relationships where the guy's like she's
the boss i feel so bad for both of them
for both of them no one's happy with
that arena i mean no one's happy with
that there might be a situation like why
won't he just step up and do the things
hold on james what you look at lions
right uh-huh and the male lion
lays lazes about does nothing the women
do all the work get all the food he eats
whatever he wants first goes back to
sleep and then she has all the babies
he's got it no yeah i mean isn't that
what's going on with these guys not
fulfilling but that's the thing and i've
said this before we live in a culture
where women are acting like men and men
are acting like children
and part of the reason women are acting
like men is because the men are acting
like children and someone needs to usurp
that role unfortunately i'm not sure
well the government is that's what's
happened the government has has
destroyed for example the black family
absolutely
the the fact that 75 percent of black
babies pre-welfare were born in two
parent homes and now it's the reverse
what's happened is that uncle sam has
taken over the role of the father the
provider in the home perhaps i mean i've
heard that quite a bit but i wonder if
it's just how about we just address
that first point in in whatever form so
uh for instance black lives matter wants
to disrupt the nuclear family i don't i
don't know if we need to come out and be
like welfare specifically other than to
just say hey families are good families
well yeah it's it's the culture it's
it's always a feedback loop but the
culture predicated the policy and then
the policy exacerbated the culture
because it didn't happen overnight
i want to i want to talk about that yeah
that's what i mentioned one more thing
there was actually an analysis i believe
from the brookings institute which is
really fascinating because it said that
the primary reason for the breaking up
of the black family and the fatherless
epidemic which of course we are catching
up to
as well is was actually roe v wade and
the fact that women could get abortions
really subverted the family structure it
was all of it i think it was also just
the normalization with the 60s of the
disruption of you know the drug sex and
rock and roll that uh that basically the
norms of okay let's wait until we're
married before we have sex well yeah
that was totally thrown out the window
so so this this whole era was the in
infantilization of a generation yeah to
be told to live for your for your
pleasures for your short-term gains for
your whims like a child instead of
realizing you've got to roll up your
sleeves and strive for yourself that
trickles down and you know i look at uh
i hear these stories you know your
grandfather he could support a family of
five on a high school education and i'm
just like there is a lot to break down
there in in terms of you know even
immigration and stuff like that but also
these are people who fought in world war
ii and they knew the value of hard work
and they knew what it meant that if you
did not struggle to survive you did not
survive and then you get the next
generation that have all the fruits of
world war ii the the you know we we
decimated the japanese and german
industries that that you know among a
variety of things our industries explode
our economy is booming we have all of
these babies and they grew up in a world
where everything's handed to them now
i'm very i'm i'm very much uh critical
of overall of the boomer generation yeah
they've extracted a ton of wealth for
themselves they're hoarding all of that
wealth and
yeah i certainly think millennials are a
lost generation too but i think it's it
starts with this and i think it's very
simply
you know you can call it strass how
generational theory you could call it
strong men make good times good times
make weak men weak men make hard times
etc and we're in that hard time phase so
the way i view the boomer generation
some of gen x and millennials as their
children they're they're childlike
generations they don't understand
the real world and by real world i mean
take someone take a human being take
away all of their clothing
and they're everything they own and put
them in the middle of the woods
welcome to reality because that's what
life was like but we've created this
bubble of security and safety and
industry and technology and we're all
born into it
imagine starting a video game like
you're playing you know zelda but you
have every weapon and every item you
wouldn't understand what you're earning
in the video game imagine if you're
playing an rpg and your character starts
completely invincible with all of this
power and money you'd be like what am i
doing exactly why am i playing it makes
the game hard to learn when you have all
the abilities when you start well and
that's no tim i i 10 000 everything you
just said i completely agree with i mean
like the word teenager
didn't exist really like the concept of
a teenager a teen i'm i'm a teen a
pre-teen or whatever like that didn't
really happen i don't think until the
50s like is the word teenager in the
bible no is it in the odyssey no like
it's a concept it is a
wealthy post-industrialized rich country
spoiled who's living off the backs of of
the greatest generation
you want to give you want to get real
real uh offensive to everybody
feminism only exists in secure wealthy
nations absolutely ten thousand percent
it's a luxury it's a luxury item in yeah
well it's a correction mechanism it
redistributes the wealth because once
that society has feminism it starts to
collapse in the societies that actually
have their gender holds together sexual
roles together take over but it's also
the case that with the boomers what's so
tragic about that generation is we look
back on them and when i say we i'm
talking about the common narrative not
necessarily what people here believe
but people look back on them as if they
were this incredible revolutionary
generation that came in and shook the
foundations dude their parents had lived
through the great depression and then
lived through the second world war many
of them fighting in it and even those
who didn't fight it had to struggle
through the hard times of rationing and
then with all of the wisdom that their
parents had accumulated they turned
around and were like we need to give
them our wisdom they're like mom and dad
no i'm gonna go to a rock and roll
concert and have sex with strangers and
we look back on this as if it we call it
a a revolution it was the sexual
revolution and that's great if you
understand the term revolution the way i
do which is in a negative connotation
but to glorify that kind of behavior it
was a generation of spoiled teenagers
who ended up ruining their inheritance
no totally and it's not progressive at
all it is regressive talking about like
what you were talking about our
ancestors living in
huts and you know i have native american
ancestors so i can say this uh you know
it's it's
savage it's it's living in uh you know
societies that are uh you know
promiscuous that's that's it's
regressive to go back to that
marriage was it isn't it was an
innovation
for women i i don't i'm not as negative
on feminism as as you are sheamus you
know no one is so you know when i say
you know getting a little getting
offensive
i think it's a fact that if you look
across the world at all of these
countries the countries that are least
secure it's very difficult for women to
to have rights to have power because
war conflict aggression but i i think we
need we need a healthy balance i
certainly think there's been instances
of you know uh men controlling too much
and women being less involved but now
we're going the other way where our
society is becoming overtly feminine i
think there needs to be a happy medium
of of a matriarch and a patriarchal kind
of approach to things like a mother and
a father there's a meme where
someone's like he's standing on a cliff
and he says
accompany boards should have a man and a
woman and everyone's like yay and then
he goes a child should have a mother and
a father and they're like boom but i'm
like no i i think that
that it scales and there is a benefit to
a masculine and a feminine view and if
it skews too much in one direction you
get you know authoritarianism in in
different ways yeah well and i would say
and this is part of why i still
disregard feminism even though i
absolutely agree that in many parts of
the world women are treated like dirt
and also throughout history men have not
always treated women well obviously
humans are a fallen species but in those
systems it's not that you have a
patriarchy it's that you have an
extremely disordered patriarchy where
the men are effeminate they're not
virtuous they don't stand up for their
women and protect them they treat them
poorly because their conception of the
the relationship between men and women
is women need to give give give and i
need to take take take whereas the way
men are supposed to operate is as giving
and women
are to operate essentially as receptive
based on any kind of natural law vision
of the world let's let's do a hard hard
segue because we we went off into a
whole new universe on that one we have
this uh story we were gonna we i said
we're gonna talk about it we got this
from cnn scientists slam joe rogan's
podcast episode with jordan peterson as
absurd and dangerous absurd absurd what
are they talking about how's the
greatest podcast ever i was listening to
some of it i'm saving it because we're
i'm going on a trip this weekend so i
was like i want to be able to listen to
the full four hours but jordan peterson
really does does say absurd you know
like kind of like
but uh anyway
that's neither here nor there uh uh this
segment is not about
cnn complaining about joe rogan's
podcast it's about joe rogan's basically
the new york times
i've talked about this before setting
the news cycle what is the story we
should be talking about the new york
times above the fold front page news
story ukraine invasion russia ghost
are we talking about whatever it is that
new york times cares about not really
we're talking about what jordan peterson
and and joe rogan want to talk about
jo i said jordan before joe rogan is
effectively because he said joe rogan i
said jordan he's become the new york
times so when cnn is like scientists are
are upset at joe rogan's podcast over
his story joe has just gotten them
to talk about climate change and now
here we are addressing the issue joe
rogan's been in the news cycle non-stop
for like what now months yeah over the
guests he's been having and it's in with
increasing frequency check this out
first you have cnn
joe rogan and jordan peterson we have
the verge spotify can't afford to lose
joe rogan now it's not even about neil
young anymore it's just about him we
have this from the independent what is
this one joe rogan podcast guest claims
pandemic this is a money grab and
they're trying to kill us once again and
that's it's jordan peterson
so so
what i see here is
look man you know we're we're
effectively becoming the joe rogan
review podcast but i'm gonna talk about
this but to be honest we were the cnn
review podcast before that we criticized
the media we criticized the mainstream
press the media lies and now that joe is
basically taking over you know dictation
of the news cycle it is becoming
prominent it is becoming common to
discuss the ideas that he's talking
about in fact so prominent i believe i
could be wrong but i believe the 13th
biggest podcast in the us is the joe
rogan experience review
whoa yeah it's like some guys talking
about what joe rogan talked about wow
yeah is he the number one joe rogan
isn't on uh
uh itunes anymore oh yeah spotify so of
course he's number one on spotify right
never moving but uh uh on on on itunes i
think it's number 13 is the joe rogan
review
podcast so this is so interesting to me
and watching the mainstream media try to
slam podcasts is like this huge source
of miss and disinformation it's really
intriguing to me because it looks like
they're starting to wake up to the fact
that joe rogan is in fact calling the
shots like you're you're saying he is in
fact controlling the narrative he's
making them talk about this one thing
that he wants to talk about and whether
they realize it or not they're very much
responding to exactly what he's doing
which if you were a very clever person
i'm sure he could use exactly to his
advantage and you're right i do think
that should give us a lot of hope as far
as the right is concerned i think that
this means that the media is kind of
starting to pay attention to the right
starting to hopefully perhaps maybe
cater to the right not that we really
necessarily want them to but it's
definitely a factor and things are
definitely shifting so perhaps the tide
is turning i was i was right real quick
just pull it out oh yeah yeah i've got
the itunes top charts joe rogan
experience review podcast number 13. and
father mike schmitz is still top 10 with
the bible in a year he was the number
one podcast he was the number one
podcast he's father what a waste he's i
hate us so attractive but that is
exactly
priests there are so many look the
priesthood is not just for men who are
not uh attractive if you are an
attractive young man do not think your
vocation would be a waste can you be a
female priest no that's a priestess we
don't have those yeah priestess
i don't consider him on the right at all
and by any means the dude wants like
universal basic income he's super like
kind of left libertarian um but anything
that's not far left these days people
are like it's it's right because they're
trying to centralize i think like joe
regan i think of him as independent like
i really do and yes anything that is not
marxist is right-wing yeah but i just
think of him as independent i've
mentioned this before but when i
i'm on my first day of college or in the
very at the very least it was the first
class i ever took at college i was at a
local community college and
this this was in 2013 and my art teacher
recommended the joe rogan experience
and at the time
the art teacher was liberal today he
would probably be considered if he has
the same opinions independent or right
wing i remember thinking what is this
like liberal garbage podcast he's about
to recommend me i remember when i first
listened to joe rogan i enjoyed it but i
was like oh yeah this guy's definitely
like on the left but i kind of want to
hear his opinions and now joe rogan is
considered this far-right figure it's so
bizarre how quickly that [ __ ] that's
that's i think what happened to trump
because it's like trump don't that was
one reason i was actually a never
trumper in 2016. i
i now i'm totally ashamed to admit this
please don't hate me i was living in new
york so the vote didn't matter i i wrote
in ben sasse i totally regret my 2016
vote but i was a never trumper till the
end but then in 2020 i proudly voted for
trump but one of the reasons why i was
never trumper was that i thought that
trump wasn't a conservative i was like
this guy donated to hillary clinton
uh he has no track record that i can
look to to suggest that he would do
anything that's conservative um but i
think just by how insanely marxist the
democrat party had become
that's that's who he he was an
independent person and he donated to
both sides um but you know i think i was
unwilling to break my my perception and
my bigotry toward this notion of someone
had to have this label as conservative
or liberal
so i was just looking at the the podcast
charts someone had commented on one of
my podcasts and they said
i referred to democrats as city urban
liberal types
and city urban liberal types that's cult
that's right that's true that's cult
they were like did you mean to do that
and i was like oh wow i did not
i was just like these city earthquakes
there we go we got a new acronym
i love this idea too that alternative
media is dangerous and these podcasters
are dangerous as if it was the
alternative media that lied us into a
20-year long war as if it was
alternative media that refused to
entertain the possibility that this
virus could have been manufactured as if
it was alternative media that was trying
to suppress whistleblowers and remove
people's platforms from them it's so
obvious well don't you know that it was
actually uh joe rogan who ordered that
uh missile strike on abdul rahman oh
yeah oh my gosh do you guys remember
that he was that child 16 year old kid
who was who was killed in a drone strike
in uh in yemen oh my gosh and uh barack
obama was was sitting at his table and
it was uh uh you know his his his uh
cabinet comes in and they're like mr
president
we got a child that needs to die and
obama was like uh
joe what do i do
and then joe was like look man look you
got you got to bomb this kid
and then they smoked some dmt well
that's the insane thing right these
people are such lap dogs for the
establishment and when they say that
these podcasts are threatening we all
know what they're really saying is that
they are a threat to our control i don't
know if it's funny enough for a for for
a bit or whatever but it would be you
know the gag i'm imagining is like the
new york times is researching like the
iraq wmds and joe rogan sitting in the
room
and he's like they got they got weapons
he's like he's like smoking and he's
like yo they got weapons of mass
destruction like are you sure dude i'm
so sure and they're like oh they're
gonna do it trump's like you know you
know what i think there was russian
collusion like all of the conspiracy
every story like just
who died last august
joe rogan ordered joe biden to drop that
yeah exactly exactly these people are so
dangerous it's so frightening who uh hey
who convinced the american people or
tried to convince the american people
that it was a great idea to uh engage in
literally the largest transfer of wealth
that's ever existed in all of human
history and print trillions of dollars
was that alternative media why is food
so expensive right now joseph joe rogan
joe rogan
he's in a room chilling with bezos and
bill gates and he just goes yeah i'm
just saying there's too many people
oh my gosh remember when that was like
that you know what i actually heard that
margaret sanger is an ancestor of joe
rogan oh yeah and i run to the family
what if what you know it's funny like
we're joking about it and the and
obviously the joke is that they they
keep accusing him of being so dangerous
or whatever that we're jokingly tying to
all these things i think that would be
one of the best conspiracies ever that
like joe actually is the leader of the
illuminati and he keeps alex close
because you've got to keep your friends
close but your enemies close
so he keeps alex jones on standby
no one would suspect no he's the foil
they're just like like five years from
now they try to claim that joe was on
the exact opposite side of every issue
that he was actually on because people
reflect on the past like remember when
joe rogan was like crazy in favor of the
mandates and in the media we were like
that's irresponsible man
that's what they it's it's remarkable i
mean that's kind of what we're seeing
now when you see these these like you
know that's why i'm critical of bill
maher to a certain degree yeah
because it's like when when bill maher
came out and said fouch you can't tell
me what to do it's like fauci said do as
you're told in november of 2020. and now
he's coming out acting like haha i'm
defiant it's just like dude you're not
convincing anybody you know so i'll tell
you what'll happen
for one the point of this segment was to
point out that joe owns the news cycle
he could he he could he talks about
with jordan peterson climate change and
all of a sudden that's like the
conversation people are having it's
remarkable because everyone knows he he
owns it so
moving forward i think what's going to
happen is with like evangeline lily
these celebrities they know
they know what's popular
ethan klein our good friend over the h3
podcast you see him coming out and
mocking joe rogan over and over again
and it's just like dude
like you're choosing the losing side of
this
freedom free inquiry is winning and all
the smear campaigns and everything they
want to do it just doesn't work
because
what it comes down to is what people
want is authenticity
the people who listen to joe know he's
not a scientist they know he's not a
doctor yeah they know he's not the
smartest guy in the world and you like
you can look at the comments and they're
just like he's just a guy and that's
what it was with vice in in the late
2000s in the early 2010s
vice was authentic you you got to the
way the way it was described is that
vice was like if your bar buddy went to
afghanistan and they'd be talking to you
like a friend about what they
experienced and telling a story as
opposed to a guy in a suit being like
let me tell you as the authority
so that's what joe's embodied regular
dude having conversations with a bunch
of crazy people asking questions and i
got to be honest joe's not even
particularly adversarial he's not yeah
like when he had uh josh's episode we
you know i ranted about him quite a bit
who insinuated i was all right joe
defended me but
still rather passively and then and then
he tweeted when when people are making
fun of him over his myocarditis segment
with josh sepps he said i love the guy
and i'm glad he was able to you know
show me or whatever he's still not
particularly at particularly adversarial
so it's it's i will say it's absurd to
me
that the media
is going after him so hard
when joe had had uh he had sanjay gupta
on yep and defended sanjay after the
fact when sanjay wrote an article saying
i was scared joe rogan was going to jump
the tail on his table and throttle my
neck when i brought that up joe was like
come on he's just trying to be funny and
i'm like
i okay sure but i wouldn't give him the
benefit of the doubt i think he
genuinely was scared i mean the dude
admitted he never had a three-hour
conversation with another human being
that's crazy yeah
how is that possible i i i've been doing
you have a wife right has he called has
he gone to school i think he met like a
one-on-one interview oh interview i
think that was what he was implying but
hold on hold on benefit of the doubt
here yeah
i i've probably
thousands upon thousands of times i've
had three hour conversations with tons
of different people from who you have i
know outside of this show not science
but
it's not normal though most people don't
do that oh come on dude i feel like it
is normal to have a three hour three
hours one on one normal yeah that's
pretty normal i'd be at my friend's
house all the people here if everyone's
like it's totally normal you guys that's
totally normal well so do you think
we're not talking about people
hold on hold on carrie thinks it's
normal yeah this thing is not i think
it's completely identical i don't even
talk that much i think it's normal and
do you think it's normal no no but but
hold on like you know we come from very
different backgrounds all of us here
yeah so it may not be a great sampling
but my my story is i'd be uh hanging out
at my friend's house you know on like a
saturday evening or whatever it would be
me and like one or two other people and
we would talk for like five or six hours
while like you know some music was
playing in the background right but
you're not listening the whole time like
people will fall and then they'll be
like huh or like you're zoned out and
you'll be like looking at something
while they're talking or like there will
be times when no no no no no they're
going
you are you are you are
making up what i just said interpreting
you're sitting for five hours we're
literally sitting here
a group of friends had two or three
people yeah we're sitting in the
backyard and we're talking about space
and time and aliens and we would just
talk for hours i see that too taco bell
we'd sit there for four hours yeah free
refills yeah at my friend's house
i would go to wendy's and i would buy
like 30 bucks worth of wendy's and just
get back that's back with the dollar
menu so i get like 20 cents
joe rogan and that inflation damn yes
exactly
17 years ago and we'd be sitting there
on my friend's couch and it'd be me and
maybe one or some other person and we
would just be like
i remember having conversations about
how time could what time is and we're
talking about gravity just having the
exact same kind of kind of conversations
that joe would be having yeah
that was that was normal for me and
politics too yeah i'd be talking about
all this stuff so for me when when he
mentioned like i've never even had a
conversation this long i'm like at some
point in your life at least once you've
never done this i i mean i mentioned
this at home i think it was last night
and i was like this blew my mind i could
not believe that he hadn't had a
conversation that that long but to get
back to your point i think that joe
rogan and the joe rogan fight really
highlights the difference between the
elite and just a regular person and the
elite think that they need that we need
them to tell us what to do and all we
want is someone who's genuine and they
can't get it through their heads they do
not understand that and you know the
fight will never end and that that that
is the actual threat to democracy that
is what the elite mindset is the actual
threat to democracy joe rogan is the
people right he isn't he's the opposite
of the threat to democracy like that
that's what i am so angry about you know
the washington post
motto democracy dies and dark like that
is the most disgusting
that's an evil motto because it is so
every article they produced that they
just did a big hit job on the
independent women's forum which was full
of lies uh and and i'm like you actually
this elite institution which had a very
storied history has become so corrupt
that uh their claims again words don't
matter
if you're throwing that phrase around
you actually don't know what it means
it's the people look at what the
washington post does what they say what
they do they say democracy dies in
darkness
we need more darkness yeah yeah exactly
that's what they're doing yeah they did
a hit piece on you they did a hit piece
on a 16 year old boy for no reason
that wasn't even newsworthy yeah it
wasn't even a story what it was about
insane the covenant
oh yeah well he he got his do we didn't
get our payout yeah unfortunately
it's like having the washington post
right about you is like slipping outside
of a fancy restaurant you're just like
hoping like all right this might be able
to turn into a lawsuit for me did they
go too far are you guys considering
suing them
if i if we were i couldn't tell you but
uh but they basically went after an
organization we have so we have a a
membership group called the independent
women's network and our policy director
hadley uh wrote a it was a form letter
like just a suggestion of a letter you
could write to your kid your um your
school the kids you know if they're
being forced to wear masks very polite
letter just kind of ideas on what to
include in the letter and the washington
post takes it uh and they infiltrated
our group they someone bought a fake
membership and leaked it to the
washington post and um they're like
uh this you know evil coke back grouped
because we get some money not i can't
disclose how much but we do get some
money from the coke network but we get
money from a lot of other organizations
but they put it on the front page and
they're like they're trying to spread
misinformation and uh basically
encourage you know extremism and
violence at school boards and encourage
people to to be riled up and and tell
moms to be uh you know demonic and i'm
obviously uh you know using flourish
words but that's basically what they
were saying because of this very polite
form letter um
and and actually the the letter itself
included studies um that that explicitly
you know very well regarded studies
about the the efficacy and the problems
with mass the story didn't even address
any of the studies all they did was
their their hype properly and just um it
was it was really upsetting
but not surprising well yeah they
usually will address the mandate and not
the
the actual science yeah
no but but to the point earlier we were
talking about uh threat to democracy so
i wrote the piece recently for the new
york post and i was looking at research
about just how bigoted liberals are so
there was a study a poll looking at uh
you know i looked at many polls but this
one looked at college campuses and how
bigoted republican students were versus
democrat students it found that thirty
percent of democrats and only seven
percent of republicans said they would
not work for someone who voted
differently from them
and
also this polling was done by axios and
generation lab which are not right-wing
organizations
and they also said that only five
percent of republican college students
said they wouldn't befriend someone from
the opposite party versus 37 percent of
democrats
and then
republicans uh 71 percent of democrats
said they would not date someone who was
uh a republican versus thirty one
percent oh they weren't
so sad
oh man that's horrible
i think well it's also interesting
they're bigoted in other ways too there
was a a study which showed that
white liberals
were likely to dumb down their language
when talking to black people in white
conservatives or not yeah that was
really revealing but did it shock you at
all no there was no part of me that read
that and went what i can't believe this
right now
would they would they really do that
this was a big red pill for i can't
remember who we were talking to was it
was it batia baby yeah she i think she
was saying that that was the like the
red pill moment for when she read that
was like is if this is true like that's
that says something yeah
and it says it and it says it in a
dumbed-down
yeah because it looks down on you it
thinks that you exist as a pawn for its
political agenda yes yeah well it's the
uh city urban liberal types yep yep
that's right city urban i sense a
t-shirt coming out yeah it's a good one
hey is that why women are more likely to
be a part of it
cult we were just talking women are more
likely to have been cultured so we'll
make women shirts are you saying we
should make a t-shirt that's not what i
said i was it was a quick little
off-the-cuff joke didn't like had to
explain it never picked the shirt i'm
going to put that on assuming the people
who do the merch for tim cast listen are
listening yeah of course yeah always
yeah so hey we'll do city urban liberal
types that's a good job that is a really
good shirt
let's make it all right let's read super
chats if you haven't already smash the
like button or as i i posted uh in the
chat smoosh mush the like button
and uh uh sending those super chats
we'll try and we can go to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have a
members only podcast up around 11 or so
p.m uncensored at timcast.com
all right let's read what we got here
lam ah i am says
ian the federal reserve speaks of making
their own crypto and now the biden admin
is using the national security apparatus
to attack them why is that
kryptos that is interesting they're
going to regulate it they want to
regulate it i have heard that central
bank crypto i think that it is going to
be done i might even not be done on a
blockchain so they although they call it
crypto it's not the same thing you can
have a crypto that's not on a blockchain
and not secured
what's it going to be it's going to be
called war coin and every single time we
go to war with another country it's just
going to skyrocket
sheamus
can you read this next super chat right
here
hold on tim here is some money to get
seamus an ireland flag a pot of gold and
a saint joseph's statue to go behind his
wall from one irish light another i
think that's beautiful frankly if we
could get like a people flag behind me
perfect what did saint joseph do st
joseph um
mary oh that's joe yeah st joseph
he was the foster father of jesus just
your average joe
absolutely i heard he was he was i think
he was the second holiest of all the
saints oh he is he like adopted jesus
right well he was the foster father yeah
that's uh
let's read some more let's read some
more uh
what's it says visit says good job
sheamus getting tim pool as a guest on
your show thank you
irl you're welcome but
and i've gotten tim on my show
i've done tim's show plenty of time uh
timmy tunes
yeah where he does these political
cartoons they're pretty good yeah every
now and again i'll come and voice dr
fauci for him that's great
i like your jordan peterson though thank
you so much
it is it is a life accomplishment of
mine to have a voice acting credit for
those that don't know i am the voice of
dr fauci
people never know people never know i'll
mention that you're the voice of doctor
like wait really wait like can we hear
it uh you don't need to be wearing two
masks
it was dude we probably improv like it's
awesome it's a rougher version of his
actually
yeah well also like i love it
i put a little slate at the end every
video that lists donors and also lists
credits so tim gets listed in the
credits and you have you actually have i
am uh internet movie database imdb right
yeah credits for your documents you get
royalties every time it's played that's
actually how he's funding this
that's
where it's like
the the joke is that sheamus the
royalties from freedom tunes are what
fund everything and everything it's like
we're just trying to maintain a an image
we should do that
we absolutely should dude it's so funny
because like i've seen one or two
comments on the vlogs they're like
i wonder if like sheamus and chris are
just joking or if they really do those
things it's like this is i thought it
was obvious that we were like doing a
bit i couldn't
all right let's read some more wait some
more we got to uh aiden says tim you
should have on maxime bernier on the
show leader of the people's party of
canada trucks just passed my house today
also carrie you look beautiful
he said he said no so maxine when i
asked him was doing like a really
hardcore uh campaign so he's too busy
but we try again well yeah i mean yeah
keep in mind that doing a show like this
is good for your campaign bro it's true
well look look look it's just a matter
of time i don't i don't i don't i don't
like the uh
like people are busy busy people you
know if they have time for us and they
want to do us a favor and come on like i
appreciate it we don't pay guests to
come out we cover their costs and
everything they don't yeah we don't pay
yeah sheamus actually we never paid his
costs we just you know we tricked it it
wouldn't pay my costs no
actually we pay shaves the most i saw i
think it's dan crenshaw's about to start
a podcast i think is that right
um what do you guys think about like
every congress person having their own
podcast probably a good thing i don't
want to hear anything more from any of
those people well you get to listen at
your own leisure i guess true too i
think they should man i want to hear
more from them and the president ted
cruz does
how many people are like
how many
people who work in politics how many
people who are actual elected
representatives have like anything
remotely interesting to say ever
uh trey gowdy did three percent every
now and then i'm not saying there's i'm
not like some of them some of them
yeah yeah every now and again in ron
paul oh my goodness but i'm saying it's
very uncommon it's very uncommon but
then again if the market was just
saturated with a bunch of elected
leaders having podcasts we would see
which ones were the top yeah yeah
if donald trump had a podcast it would
be like six hours a day yeah six hours
yeah he would just because he just would
turn the mic on and start talking with
two points this is who you follow i
would call fat today
here's a list it's 12. it's going to
take about a half hour to get through
this okay
none of these people all of these people
drink diet coke for sure
all right let's read some more
what do we got here uh anthony says
why don't the trucker protest california
new york and all these states that are
enforcing mass management vaccine
mandates yeah where's the u.s trucker
protest i suppose after they do the
convoy in canada they should keep it
going but they haven't specifically
targeted truckers it was a you know
blanket mandate right yeah in america
like they haven't gone off for truckers
oh right right right yeah isn't that the
problem well the issue now is that
canada it's the border yeah that is if
you want to cross the border you got to
be vaccinated and unvaccinated americans
can't even enter canada but uh
unvaccinated canadians have to
quarantine after entering so it's jammed
up traffic in both directions i don't
know if that's the sole reason for the
protest that's a big reason
all right let's see we got
just a cook named josh that say tim love
your show as i've made it a daily
routine every day it is a canadian thank
you for making news of the freedom
convoy 2022 as the authoritarian
government censors us we are not going
to stop like and share
yes tell everybody about the story man
there there was also another protest i
think people confused where they were
truckers were concerned about icy
conditions it actually happened and some
people are suggesting it was a psyop
because what happens is when this
trucker convoy breaks you know comes out
right i heard reports that like only
some trucks are blocking the the borders
and it's no big deal then you actually
look at the social media and it's like
hundreds of truckers are starting this
thing
then all of a sudden there's a protest
where it's like truckers engage in you
know massive political action and i
clicked it and it was like uh seven
trucks with signs saying you know fix
the icy conditions and then i was like
wait what what what oh they spun up
another protest to diffuse from the
protest so the conspiracy theory is
to to immediately trick people into
thinking there's no real big 50 000
trucker protest you stage a small one
then tell everyone oh that trucker
protest you heard about there it is that
that said those seven trucks yep they
are upset about it
your search optimization results i mean
i know icy conditions are dangerous but
i
i've never heard of a protest about icy
conditions this might have to do with
that just seems insane
what do we want more salts
that was like remember like a couple
months ago the trucker was coming down
the hill and hit a bunch of people so it
might have something to do with that but
i thought it was more his breaks i think
it was well he was supposed to take
those there was the the the off-ramp
thing for runaway trucks he was supposed
to go through he didn't and they blamed
him like they came down with him on a
hundred years in prison
there was a good argument from the
truckers but was it icy i don't think it
was no but they might be like argument
we're not driving if you're gonna blame
us for that the argument was that if
he's treated if you're if you're holding
a powerful device be it a gun or a truck
you're responsible for what happens so
if you crash it that's his fault he
should have engaged in this proposition
yes did you hear that's what they're
trying to do in milwaukee they're
actually i cannot believe what it's
liberal so i can believe it
so these the milwaukee city council i
kid you not wants to sue
the two most popular uh you know the
makers of the two most popular cars in
the area that are getting hijacked
because there are too many carjackings
now in the city of milwaukee and so they
want to sue them for making the cars too
easy that's like she shouldn't have worn
that walking that's exactly what i said
i wrote a piece about this and i said
this is the equivalent of victim shaming
and saying that the the rape victim
deserved it because she was wearing a
skirt or a blouse it's it's they want
these car companies to make uglier cars
they wanted to make them easier to hide
or harder to hijack
yeah
not harder to want to hijack right now
uglier more secure i want to i just want
to mention one more thing here about
this trucker shortage as we were
mentioning earlier in the podcast 20 of
truckers who cross the border as many as
20 are unvaccinated we sort of stopped
talking about this in general it was a
story a few months ago but there is
still a trucker shortage yep so to do
this right now again just to just to
really hit home the absurdity of this
it's insane can you believe it it's
actually ridiculous people don't know
this but saying the word absurd is the
hypnotic command to trigger trigger
shamus becoming jordan peterson
let's read some more what trash panda
says can't think of a better birthday
present for me today than seeing my
fellow truckers spit in the eye of
pirates happy birthday happy birthday to
you happy birthday keep on trucking all
right bill bill lemon says can we have a
cage match between sheamus and luke last
man standing stays in the show
permanently
so this is the thing luke and i have
interacted around the house a number of
times i'm always very kind and gracious
to him he's got a chip on his shoulder
he's always yelling at me
you can see it on the vlog people people
don't realize this but ireland and
poland have beef no story
no i mean in all honesty uh luke is luke
is is someone who i really like whose
work i like very much and tim had to put
me in this unfortunate position of being
pitted against him and it's sad because
to be honest i will say this i will say
this uh i really admire the polish
especially poland as a country very good
captain if you were going to wrestle
the pope that uh helped defeat john paul
yeah polish yeah the pope then knew how
to pope yeah would you wrestle luke on
land or in like a foot of water i never
said i never said i wouldn't wrestle him
i'd wrestle luke anywhere underwater
yeah underwater would be yeah i just i
would be upset about it but like i would
of course i would do it would you do it
if he identified as the female because
then you'd be attacking a female no
because he wouldn't actually be a female
you know so you would still wrestle i
would still wrestle him see even you
just said because
check it out uh damien says tim i got a
mobile led billboard as of tonight i
have both breaking news on it first
about the truckers second is that the
man that got denied the heart transplant
oh we should we should buy some
billboards yes we should this man
let's do a billboard
no we should do a building c-u-l-t yeah
oh here don't move here if you're a no
we'll just we'll just do it and we'll
we'll we'll put it you know it's gonna
be really funny we think we're being all
smart and edgy like haha cult and then
it becomes like an actual popular thing
like how monopoly did yeah like you know
monopoly was originally made to make fun
of capitalism yeah we could get one of
them really i don't know no like let's
buy a real billboard i'm saying like
actually get sunset boulevard the
problem is they're not worth it anymore
we noticed this with minds when we were
doing market research is like
super bowl ads billboards they were so
expensive and the return was so low
relative to like facebook ads yeah so if
you really want to hit a target audience
you go to the facebook ads because then
there's click-throughs
what's something we can do with facebook
ads that would just be have a marketing
guy who's great so well i don't mean i
don't mean marketing i don't i don't
care if people learn who we are
necessarily i'm saying just to like you
know spit the eye of tyrants well i'm
good at making cartoons and cartoons
upset tyrants sometimes did you ever
hear the story about that guy who used
facebook's targeted advertising to freak
out his roommate
because facebook used to allow you to
directly target people based on email
addresses oh really so what he did was
he advertised to only one email address
which was his roommate and he would make
ads that said things like did you forget
to do the dishes your roommate could be
angry
and then his roommate would be like what
is going on
that's actually amazing it's brilliant
oh i love that i don't think they allow
that anymore though it's too bad that's
a shame now it's just like torture
psychological torture yeah maybe they do
maybe maybe they still allow it i don't
know it was a funny story that is funny
yeah yeah
nevermore says drink tim said occupy do
i say occupy very often
i don't know maybe i mean it occupies
some of your time
you said occupy wall street you didn't
say wall street you said occupy you were
talking about the protesters i said it
one time oh yeah okay it's funny when
people are like if tim says a certain
phrase drink and i'm like it's funny
because
there'll be like a week where i'll say
something like at the end of the day a
lot it's true and then everyone for like
a year will be like tim says at the end
of the day a lot and i'm like that's
like one week where i was in my mind and
i don't see that you said something you
said to be honest several times i did
yeah and i'm like i'm like why'd you
point it out they're gonna know now okay
that was a drink that was a little too
honest
drink no the reason why is because
i i have a friend who would say whenever
somebody says that you're like okay was
everything else lie so yeah so like
you're now caveating what you're saying
does that mean everything else is live
why are you doing this to me why are you
doing this now you're gonna know
i'm a truth teller tell the truth to be
honest
all right we got this from nick he says
my parents are what i call fox news
republicans i've been trying to get them
to listen to you tim i showed them a
five minute clip and they said they
agreed with what you said keep up the
great work cool so uh we were talking
about the other day
every so often the segment i do at 4 pm
tucker carlson will then do
on his nightly show i don't do the
entirety of his show because he does you
know an hour whatever but like my you
know 10 minute you know segment or
whatever which i stretches out for a
variety of reasons he would talk about
that in his and i think that has a lot
to do with um
like the the i guess the the cultural
zeitgeist that in this political space a
conversation emerges that everyone sees
and starts talking about you know what i
mean
so yeah well i mean i told you not to do
that segment about the m m's
but you still did it and then we had
tucker carl that was a weird expression
on your face when you said that you were
like this is a great i was like i'm
gonna get i'm gonna make fun of you
tim's gonna get this sheamus made fun of
tucker carlson and lou got really mad
yeah oh my gosh that's so right because
here's the thing
and people know generally speaking i'm a
fan of tucker carlson to be honest i
enjoy his work honestly but i wasn't
gonna not make fun of him for the eminem
segment so i just kept doing this
impression of him and everyone was
cracking up except for luke luke luke
was like you know what he made a mistake
let him be
but i think he was mostly joking no he
was mostly joking he was mostly joking
it was it was it was a dumb thing yeah
did you guys see the eminem segment
that's a great sex he's like why aren't
eminem's attractive to me anymore
yeah i guess well he was comfortable
he's complaining because uh the green m
m was in high like high stilettos and
there were boots they were like go go
boots like like thigh high sexy boots
like boots that i would want to wear
what is wrong with being sexy like what
is wrong with being feminine what is
wrong with that i don't know for sure
but i just want they want us to be
androgynous
we're talking about an eminem like i
don't i think it's very weird yeah like
especially you ever see that meme where
it's like it's like never forget what
they took from you and it's lola bunny
from the 90s
from the new one that's true i took her
boobs away
i'm like yo i'm not i've never been
concerned but maybe there are furries or
some people who are like
you know they they
that's actually a meme too yeah i mean
the thing is i just never really thought
about it i never thought about her
having those boots until someone said
something about it but then but now i'm
angry that they took them away i think
the bit you should do sheamus is that
they can't you should go the other
direction with it and make make make the
candy 10 times as sexy absolutely not no
that is and it's disgusting well no i
but i always thought it was weird yeah
why are they big [ __ ]
i thought it was weird
i just i always i thought it was very
weird that when it came to the mascots
eminem decided one of the m m's needed
to have like some version of sex appeal
that was always a strange thing it's
like they're eminent are they appealing
to you it's because we just have this
absolutely
and like i'm not sure and
i guess the best thing in terms of
giving them the benefit of the doubt is
that they're sort of parodying like a
stereotype with this eminem of like this
is what you know there's always that
token
smoking the cigarette in the commercial
and it's like trying to target people
make them feel more attractive when they
smoke let's read some more super chats
we got a good one here from nova zero he
says those of us aussies who who know
you use a vp you use a vpn i turn it off
for the super chat so you know where i
am but likewise you don't know us avi
isn't the only one fighting here aussie
cossack and friendly jordi's we exist
you know yes absolutely i'm familiar
with avi um
um principally i know there's a lot of
other people there i've i have some
friends in a couple different cities i
talk to them about what's going on
there's obviously people organizing
protests and pushing back i did not mean
to suggest that literally no australian
person is is protesting i'm just saying
that
you know when ian pointed out quillette
under duress
i can immediately point to avi who i'm
familiar with for a variety of reasons
right and uh you guys as well so so you
know good luck and invite the good fight
and i hope australia learns its lesson
and backs off the insanity
all right adrian curry says marxism is
like the hallmark channel it's a lie
women get addicted to because it makes
them feel good interesting the hallmark
channelers
it does seem and it makes sense
for the hallmark channel no
that makes you think mentally no
no it says cult men or evil yes exactly
urban men are evil that's awesome you
got to move to the country and find a
good that's right family oriented you
know what you know me around on this
yeah all right z says you know i'm an
atheist but after hearing that mormon
comment i think i'm going to be a mormon
lol
which one was that though was that that
cult or something i think i thought
there's more oh the polygamy baby
yeah
makes sense i think they've done away
with that have they
well actually no exactly on paper they
do believe in the afterlife so the
mainstream mick church as i like to say
the mitt romney church the big one
they do believe in polygamy in the
afterlife like they believe the
structure of heaven is polygamous are
they t-totes
oh yeah yeah
no so they're monogamous in life yeah so
so i think it was like family guy or
some show where they were like wait when
you're a mormon you have multiple wives
like yes they're like sign me up and
then they were like wait no beer oh and
they ran away
but in the afterlife you don't need
booze right i mean everyone's happy are
they monogamous in life and then when
they die they think they have a bunch of
wives well actually on earth you can
technically be sealed to multiple women
usually in matters of death or divorce
so for an example
my aunt charlotte
was
gorgeous she was miss usa she was miss
utah usa she was stunning
i don't want to say to i
i will hold my tongue about her
ex-husband but basically
she put on some weight and then he
divorced her and married a younger
you know skinnier woman
they had had eight children together
and uh
because they believe you need to be
married in order to go to the highest
level of heaven she she passed away god
rest her soul
she never found another husband to marry
so technically according to mormon
doctrine because he was still sealed to
her he will get both wives in the
afterlife oh wow that's kind of wow
that's yeah it's kind of like it always
that really angered me it really upset
me understandably yeah i mean because
i'm like this is literally the
definition of hell to me like how is
this heaven this was designed out of the
brain of a human male yeah this sounds
like a true test let's read some more
here we go
yellow cafe says the largest cult in the
world is led by jared leto he's
tattooing his followers bodies he and
his followers say the phrase yes this is
a cult to downplay that it's a cult he
has many allegations against him for
having
adult activities with with underage
individuals please look into this those
are bold accusations i'm not familiar
with
a thing about this really yeah big thing
it was interesting but but jared leto
plays that morbius guy yeah he sings
that song those songs oh right
all right let's see 30 seconds to mars
zeknik says sheamus are you courting
michaela peterson after your interview
with her and her father a lot of flirt
vibes in that interview no it was i
didn't think i was flirting at all
it's a great video sheamus did a video
with on michaela i think it's on
michaela's channel with and jordan made
a special appearance and sheamus did the
voice to his face
everyone check it out check it out it's
hilarious it was good that's awesome
you did jordan peterson's voice to
jordan oh yeah to his face it was great
it was great it was a good experience i
didn't think i was going to have to but
then i was so she can i have her
autograph yeah absolutely so she invited
me to do her podcast which was great and
so i was on and i did not expect him to
be there and she surprised me with him
uh she surprised me with with jordan
peterson being there
uh and it it blew my mind it really did
okay she likes you
what kind of she likes you [ __ ]
the best part of the interview was when
jordan got confused about who he was
it's like wait who am i looking in a
mirror right now
stay away from me he punched his
computer screen
all right
wade mikunda says tim as fauci arguing
with sheamus as jordan peterson go
well here's the thing it's like if you
here here's the deal put on your mask
jordan no i got vaccinated you're
getting dropped you leave me alone i got
vaccinated
oh man maybe maybe that should be uh
this should be ongoing
i'm not as good as shame as doing the
voices like when we do this normally i
have to like try and get into character
anthony fauci george peterson in a
paleontology museum trying to get out oh
gosh
five minutes until closing time
did you used to do improv
no so when i do the voices usually the
situation the only way it really works
especially the long ones is that sheamus
tells me how to say these things real
though so like sheamus gave me a script
once and i can read it as fouchy but to
get the actual thing right i need some i
need him you know otherwise that's my
motivation no no it's just like
you can say things like get out of my
store get out of my store get out of my
store you know what i mean get out of
there like a line
depending on how the other sentences are
going to be said it could be a question
it could be a response it could be angry
it could be sad i can't see those things
on paper so in order to actually have
like an argument do it so are you the
equivalent of color blind but with words
well no i mean sheamus is good at the
improv and just doing these voices i can
do a voice but without something to play
off of you know what i mean so like so
typically when people are like hey can
you do this person's voice i'm like i
have to actually hear them say it and i
can impersonate it
sheamus for some reason can just
literally make up a sentence that sounds
like jordan peterson from you know right
away there's something strange about my
brain but i know that when tim and i
were recorded like tim he'll give me a
read and i'll go tim you're angry people
aren't taking their vaccines they won't
wear their masks you've studied this
your whole life getting you droplets all
over me and then i go you nailed it you
got it i felt the emotion in that that
was a fun one the one where the guy's
breaking up with fouchy yeah and then
she cries
i i put that on i put that for my donors
on patreon like the entire 20-minute
recording session people were dying when
they watched it
it's so hilarious dude table reads for
voice acting is just always always so
much fun yeah sheamus and i did a really
disgusting uh uh improv we did some very
funny ones there was one disgusting one
i don't want to get into it i'll just
explain i can't see the light no don't
even explain he will never see the light
of day there's i can't i'm gone it's
it's so bad it's basically uh uh fauci
isn't
los angeles don't do this don't even
explain this
it's a common joke it's a meme yeah
that's fair so it's fauci's in la and
and someone's trying to get work and
he's like if you want to work in this
town and he's basically you know harvey
you know that's true no but they have to
get your vaccination that's right that's
that's a that's a that's a tame
description
james was like this is not acceptable
youtube would ban us instantly
yeah yep i thought you were a good
catholic i was i know that's why i was
like i can't make this no the whole time
i was like literally the whole time i
was like tim we're not doing like we are
not doing that i was like shameless
where's the edgy did you go to the
confession after that no well i didn't
think i did anything you talked to your
priest i do talk to my friends but i
don't think i did anything wrong in that
instance i kept telling him not to do
confession a lot do you like every week
or something i try to so when i'm in
when i'm at my home base and i'm you
know on a decent schedule i try to go at
least once a week is that normal for a
catholic to go every week that's a good
question do you go before you take
communion to yeah so that button that's
a ques yeah so you need to be in a state
of grace before you have the eucharist
and so if i'm not in a state of grace
i'll have to go to confession first but
it's not necessarily required that you
go to confession before every time you
have a state of grace like meditate like
into a calm state kind of that's a good
question so basically um in scripture
there's a delineation between
the kind of sin that leads unto death
specifically that are listed like
drunkards idolaters etc will not inherit
the kingdom of heaven and so we refer to
those and things under that category
basically any grave violation of the ten
commandments is a mortal sin because
that destroys your relationship with god
and then you need to be restored to a
relationship with god because as it's
mentioned in scripture christ gave his
the apostle the apostles the ability to
forgive and retain sin and so we believe
that that was passed on through
apostolic succession to modern day
priests but where in the bible did jesus
ask any confession when he gave them the
bread and wine at the last supper
because i don't recall him doing that
and i'm pretty sure that judas was not
in a state of grace yeah no so that's an
interesting question it's been argued by
science sorry tim timmy's saying this is
a whole big argument but the point later
is that yeah protestants rule but i
can't
but i can't
i can't but i can't let that stand i'll
also say that um we're not never kids we
should do this in the after show about
this about that well we can talk about
yeah so that means you gotta join but we
also got to subscribe yeah because the
thing is so i just want to mention this
in scripture paul does say you eat and
drink condemnation upon yourself if you
receive unworthily corto maltese says
i've been following you for for years
now but if this is just going to turn
into jesus cast count me out i'll call
me for the news not to hear about
christianity
well define christianity
there's organized religion then there's
living like christ and you can do that
without
hearing
i absolutely love talking about religion
um we've done several members-only
podcasts where we went like really long
talk about a bunch of stuff but uh but i
will say you know
try to uh you know if it goes too much
into it we'll try and steer it back into
news i don't want to it's not jainism i
think it's it's basically just because
we have two you know religious
individuals in the show today yeah it
comes out and also like when you're
religious your religion is baked into
your world view so it's gonna come up i
mean it's you're just gonna end up
analyzing things through that lens it's
not as if i sit here and go i wanna
force the conversation in this direction
it's just the way my brain works is when
this topic goes up i related to my world
view and wild prison through which i
have and also the united states was
founded primarily by judeo-christians so
this is a podcast about america for
americans i think that there are a lot
of people who are like our viewer here
who are secular but there are a lot of
christians and and i think the beauty of
a cosmopolitan society is that you can
have all voices we don't talk about
religion all that often to be honest but
yeah but we
do have something i got to read
discussion i'm gonna read some more
super chats it's very important
anorak says as a furry i can confirm the
fandom was devastated by the lola bunny
change made me avoid social media for a
month to stay away from the drama wow
that's actually kind of crazy i got a
message from someone who was like you
know what i identify as a furry i want
to thank you guys for kind of like
just talking about the whole furry thing
is kind of like a role play and not some
weird you know bizarre getting your
six-year-old a sex change operation or
something and
so shout out to all you furries out
there and role-playing is cool you can
do it constructively
yes furries furries have uh uh
a really bad rap you know i mean but
we've had some people who have chimed in
and talked about being a furry and you
know have have given us consistent super
chats pretty sure people are just people
in the middle i was an actor for years i
mean people do it for a living
all right what is this
kevin grip says crenshaw big
disappointment bait and switch
yeah what do you guys think about
crenshaw
when i first saw him i loved him because
of his willingness to listen i think the
thing i love about him is he's a good
listener um although i was thinking
about this the other night very
open-minded the problem with being
open-minded is that you're more
susceptible to being co-opted so if he's
there in the the swamp
and he's got people swirling around his
mind i'm afraid that he may be being
pulled in directions we are going to
have uh dan crenshaw on the show some
some point soon yep where i'm excited to
have that conversation there's been a
lot of really he's had a lot of really
bad internet press like a lot like viral
videos and stuff i mean by that and uh i
think it's interesting to
break down these questions in these
stories and ask about his world view and
and what he hopes to accomplish there
was a lot of hope for him a lot uh early
on people were really excited for dan
now it seems like a lot of the stuff
coming out is very anti you know he said
that he thought congress people should
get paid more and i was like okay
he's famous the famous congress people
get flown around they get they go to
events they can take around they need to
pay for that 175k is not enough in a
year to fly to dallas and fort worth
so then i'm like so should we pay our
famous congress people more money no
that's a bad precedent because then
they're going to be tweeting up storms
to get more famous to get more money so
like but i understand that that you need
more money
when you're higher profile to get around
we we do uh plan on having him on very
soon we don't really don't announce
dates or anything just because in the
event someone cancels we don't want to
get anyone's hopes up but luke will be
coming back for this and we're gonna
have a very serious political political
discussion foreign policy domestic
policy so i think it'll i think it'll be
good and i think you know if people
whatever they think about them they're
gonna hear a lot more from him and you
know they can use that to uh either
solidify or counter their their opinions
on them but we'll see we'll see what
happens uh how it goes down so if you
haven't already uh smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends go to timcast.com
become a member because we are going to
have a members only segment coming up
for you around 11 p.m don't forget to
follow the show at tim cast irl on
instagram and everywhere else you can
follow me at tim cast on twitter
instagram gab getter etc carrie do you
wanna shout anything out
yeah nice to meet everybody um i'll see
you in the after party show and uh if
you want to check out what we're doing
at iwf.org we are the counter to the
feminist lies
and we have a community called the
independent women's network where we
bring women and we we love men we are
women's group that loves men imagine
that so uh independent women's network
uh we'd love to have you be part of our
community we have live chats we have
message boards we have letters to send
to your school board about masking
policies things like that we will see
you there
and what's your twitter you got twitter
too oh yeah i'm on twitter yeah um
twitter getter instagram facebook uh at
carrie sheffield except for instagram
which is sheffield carrie sorry to the
other one she uh reversed the name and
got it before i did
i'm seamus coughlin and i have a youtube
channel called freedom tunes if you guys
want to check that out head on over
there subscribe we just released a
cartoon today about this insane policy
of putting masks on children which a lot
of schools have so check that out like
share subscribe spread it around i think
it's important for people on our side of
the aisle to kind of try to build
cultures is the way tim puts it but just
create content that isn't just a
discussion of politics but which is an
actual sort of lampooning of it and yeah
check me out there
shout out to all you uh muslims
christians jews hindus
buddhists jainists simulists simulists
zoroasterists
believe in a simulation and the earth is
flat and it's hollow the hollow
simulation
hey follow me in crossland.net i'll
catch you later thank you guys very much
for tuning in i suspect tonight's after
show will be fun so you guys should go
join up at timcast.com thank you all so
much for tuning in you guys may follow
me on twitter and at minds at
sourpatchlitz we will see you all over
at timcast.com for the members segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you